[Musique]
en votre nom à tous je tiens à adresser
les félicitations de la représentation
nationale à nos compatriotes Madame Anne
l'hiler et Monsieur Pierre Agostini
lauréat du prix Nobel de physique
2023 conjointement avec leur collègue
monsieur frerence
Kraus
merci beaucoup l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au Gouvernement la
première d'entre elles va être posée par
Madame Hélène Laporte pour le
rassemblement
national
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outrmes
monsieur le ministre quel démenti plus
singlant pour un homme d'État que celui
qui émane de ses propres services malgré
l'autosatisfaction à laquelle vous nous
avez habitué au sujet de votre gestion
le bilan statistique insécurité et
délinquence paru jeudi dernier nous
offre sans ambigué le sombre tableau de
l'ensauvagement de notre pays pourtant
loin d'admettre votre échec vous essayez
une fois de plus de noyer la vérité des
chiffres ce matin même vous affirmiez
que la hausse spectaculaire des
infractions en 2022 ne constiue qu'un
rattrapage après 2 années de covid c'est
faux sur toute la période
2017-2022 les homicides ont augmenté de
16 % les escroqueries de 38 % les cûts
et blessur volontairees de 52 % les
violences sexuelles de 103 %. monsieur
le ministre le covid ne pourra pas
éternellement vous servir
d'excuse toujours ce matin vous nous
annonciz en avant-première une baisse
importante de la délinquence depuis
janvier 2023 mais nous ne sommes pas
amnésique en septembre dernier vous
affirmiez déjà attendre une baisse des
violences extrafamiliales sur l'année
2022 2 les chiffres ont finalement
montré l'inverse en 2022 ces actes
étaient en forte hausse de 14 % pour les
cûts et blessures et de 11 % pour les
homicides permettez-nous donc la
prudence nous discuterons des chiffres
de 2023 quand ils paraîtront en
attendant 2022 est un désastre enfin
alors que les ressortissants étrangers
représentent 18 % des auteurs d'omicide
et 35 % des auteurs de vols violents la
très timide hausse du taux d'exécution
des otf en 2020 2 ne nous fera pas
oublier sa chute de 73 % entre 2012 et
2021 en ce qui concerne les TF il n'y a
visiblement pas eu de rattrapage post
covid en la matière monsieur le ministre
par quel prodige espérez-vous obtenir
demain des résultats différents en
poursuivant hassablement la même
politique je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur géraldanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des
outremèes bonjour bonjour madame la
Présidente MAM et monessieurs les
députés madame la député je vous
trouvais moins agressive hier avec le
président de la République lorsque dans
votre circonscription il a annoncé 285
brigades de
gendarmerie vous avez dit c'est vrai que
Madame Le Pen n'était pas là pour faire
la commissaire politique vous avez dit
au président de la République et à
moimême à quel point vous étiez heureux
de voir ses annonces pour la sécurité de
notre
pays mais il est vrai qu'on fait parfois
de la politique différemment à Paris que
dans sa propre
circonscription c'est vrai madame la
députée puisque dans le propre programme
de Madame Le Pen qui était élu elle
prévoyait 7000 postes de policiers et de
gendarmes sur le mandat nous en faisons
8500 elle prévoyait 1 milliard 5 d'euros
supplémentaires nous prévoyons 15
milliards d'euros par an pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur et nous
constaterons que dans vos 2 minutes de
question vous faites beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de référence à la politique et
a des ch mais jamais au policiers au
jendarmes à qui vous ne rendez jamais
hommage et c'est vraiment bien
dommage la vérité madame la député vous
le savez très bien vous vous acharnez
sur les chiffres 2022 puisqu'ils sont
supérieurs à des moments évidemment la
crise covid était encore là et où il y
avait par nature moins de délinquence
mais vous savez très bien que depuis les
9 premiers mois de l'année y compris
dans votre département qui atteint des
chiffres très important c'est entre 15
et 30 % délinquence sur tous les
chiffres de la délinquence et sur les
conduite à la frontière madame la
députée vous savez très bien puisque
nous avons publié les chiffres il y a un
mois nous avons 14 % de reconduite à la
frontière en plus la vérité c'est que
l'insécurité madame c'est ce qui fait
monter les voies du Front national la
sécurité les moyens pour la police c'est
ce qui fait que les gens votent pour des
partis de gouvernement et moi je suis
très heureux je suis très heureux madame
de pouvoir dire dans ma réponse que oui
je remercie avant tout les policiers
gendarmes qui font un travail
exemplaire merci beaucoup monsieur
ministre NZ plus de vous n'avez qu'une
seconde donc là je voudrais simplement
dire à Monsieur le Ministre une seconde
ben je suis désolée une seconde c'est
une
seconde la parole est à Monsieur Rémy
rbrot pour le groupe
Renaissance madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
avez fait constat que suite à des
décisions prises il y a 15 ans ou parce
que des besoins nouveaux ont émergé le
maillage de notre territoire en
gendarmerie faisait l'objet de myage et
qu'il était temps de le r
redensifier c'était l'un des objectifs
fixés par la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur la fameuse
lopmie cela correspond à un engagement
pris par le chef de l'État lors de sa
campagne présidentielle
238 nouvelles brigades fixes ou mobiles
seront créées saluons le fait que ces
annonces vont au-delà des engagements du
Président de la République qui avait
promis à l'époque 200 brigades ces
créations sont l'expression de la lopmie
qui porte donc une ambition encore plus
globale et importante dans ma
circonscription une brigade mobile à
Hain viendra répondre aux questions
spécifiques des communes du massif du
ent trois autres brigades à Toulon sur
harou lu ou pierreclaud viendront
renforcer les effectifs et combler les
manques et d'ailleurs j'associe à ma
question mes collèges sonnis loiriens
très actifs sur le sujet Benjamin Dirks
et luoui Marguerite je me dis aussi que
ce nouveau plan est exemplaire dans
d'autres domaines je pense notamment aux
structures hospitalières lorsqu'un myage
a été créé je pense par exemple au
Morvent il ne faut pas hésiter à revenir
sur des décisions qui ont été prise ma
question quelles sont les prochaines
étapes du plan annoncé et comment se
concrétiseront ces nouvelles
implantations je vous remercie monsieur
le député la parole est à Gérald armanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outremèes merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député riérotte c'est grâce
au travail du Parlement lors d'un vote
important la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur grâce au crédit
accordé par Madame la première ministre
et par le Président de la République que
nous permettons de moderniser mais en
même temps de renforcer les effectifs de
police et de gendarmerie partout sur le
territoire national monsieur le député
peut-être dans le premier kquena
avons-nous pas assez souigné que les
effectifs en plus ont permis de doubler
les effectif de la DGSI passant de 2000
à 4000 personnes déjouant ainsi un
attentat tous les 2 mois sur le sol
national augmentant les renforts dans
les grands centres urbains je pense à
Paris je pense à Marseille à Lyon à
Lille par exemple et que le deuxème
kakena et peut-être celui d'avantage de
la ruralité ou en tout cas de zone plus
périurbaines avec la création de ces 285
brigades de gendarmerie jusqu'en 2017
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
gouvernement les gouvernements pendant
20 ans ont supprimé 500 brigades
concentrant les effectifs de gendarmerie
dans les zones les plus urbaines ce que
faisait le président de la République
quand il a promis ses 200 brigade c'est
l'adaptation évidemment à des
difficultés de service public né
directement du débat autour du grand
débat et je crois que les préfets avec
les élus autant que faire ce peu ont pu
répondre en métropole et en autre m à
ces implantations nouvelles nous avons
déjà recruté 600 des 2140 gendarmes qui
permettront d'armer ces brigades de
gendarmerie ces 600 effectifs dès le
mois de décembre pourront être affectés
pour cette nouvelle brigade et chaque
année nous formerons 600 nouveaux
effectifs pour tenir les 2144 gendarmes
qu'il nous faudra évidemment mettre en
œuvre les constructions puisquils s ont
été ces brigades fixes sélectionné selon
les critères de disponibilité des
terrains commenceront dès la fin d'année
puisque dès le budget 2023 nous avons
les études et les premières
inaugurations nous l'espérons dès
2025 merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à madame la
Présidente Mathilde Panau pour le groupe
la France
insoumise madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre une vague de panique
saisit le pays les punaises de lit
prolifère dans tous les lieux du
quotidien les hôpitaux écoles foyers de
travailleurs maisons de retraite les
prisons les trains ou même les salles de
cinéma elles font vivre un calvaire aux
millions de nos concitoyens infestés
elles leur font perdre le sommeil
provoquent de la paranoïa et les isolent
socialement les punaises de lit sont un
problème national de santé publique mais
vous n'avez rien fait en 2017 il y avait
200000 lieux infestés j'ai alerté vous
m'avez riononné vous n'avez rien fait en
2019 il y avait 540000 sites infestés
nous avons manifesté pétitionné
désinsectisé des logements déposé une
résolution pour exiger un plan d'urgence
vous m'avez riononné vous n'avez rien
fait en 2020 il y avait 950000 sites
infestés nous avons interpellé le
gouvernement sur l'urgence à agir vous
m'avez rionné vous n'avez rien fait rien
ou presque un numéro vert et une
plateforme fantôme qui a depuis disparu
en 2022 il y avait 1,1 million de site
infesté vous avez agi et menti avec un
plan interministériel sans aucune mesure
contraignante et un observatoire annoncé
qui n'a jamais vu le jour madame la
Première ministre 6 ans après c'est
votre inaction qui est largement
responsable de cette situation explosive
plus vous attendez plus cette situation
devient incontrôlable quand allez-vous
enfin interdire les produits chimiques
inefficaces quand 90 % des punaises ont
développé des résistances quand
allez-vous enfin cesser de livrer les
citoyens à eux-même et à la voracité des
entreprises privées nous exigeons un
service public de la désinsectisation
gratuit efficace garant de la santé et
de l'environnement madame la Première
ministre ces petits insectes répandent
le désespoir dans notre pays fautil
attendre que matigon soit infesté pour
qu'enfin vous
réagissiez je vous remercie la parole
est à Madame Elisabeth Bor première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Mathilde
Panau il y a des sujets qui ne devrai
pas prêter à la polémique et aux
diffusions un peu de d'essence madame la
Présidente alors oui les punaises de lit
sont une angoisse pour nos concitoyens
qui craignent d'y être confrontés c'est
un véritable calvaire pour ceux qui sont
touchés l'infestation d'un logement
devenir un enfer pour celles et ceux qui
y habitent et les solutions pour s'en
débarrasser peuvent être coûteuses sur
ce sujet il ne devrait pas y avoir de
clivage il devrait y avoir une
détermination collective pour agir alors
madame la Présidente panneau pourquoi
une fois de plus restez-vous dans
l'outrance pourquoi ne dites-vous pas
pourquoi ne dites-vous pas qu'il y a un
an et demi en mars 2022 le plan
interministériel de lutte contre les
punaises de lit porté par les ministère
de la transition écologique du logement
et de la Santé a marqué l'attention du
gouvernement face à ce phénomène et
apporter des premières réponses ce plan
c'est d'abord de la sensibilisation pour
mieux pour mieux repérer les
infestations et informer particuliers et
professionnels concernés c'est aussi un
accompagnement de la filière de lutte
contre les nuisibles pour offrir de
meilleurs traitements et disposer de
professionnels formés et reconnus c'est
en effet une meilleure observation du
phénomène avec un observatoire qui est
en cours de création mesdames et
messieurs les députés les punaises de
lit ont infesté la plupart des grandes
villes du monde les études nous montrent
que leur prolifération est liée au
voyage touristique et à la résistance
aux insecticides pour autant nous sommes
déterminés à continuer à agir et
amplifier notre action et une réunion
avec l'ensemble des ministère concerné
se tiendra dans les prochains jours et
la majorité présidentielle a engagé
travail pour trouver des réponses de
long terme sur la détection
l'infestation et l'accompagnement des
personnes touchées une réflexion qui
devrait pouvoir rassembler largement
dans cet hémicycle alors travaillons
ensemble trouvons des solutions ensemble
je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre la parole est à Madame Annie
jeunev pour le groupe les républicain
merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre depuis des
mois nous Senons l'alarme la
construction et la vente de logement
s'effondre il y a 15 ans on construisit
100000 logements de plus qu'aujourd'hui
l'augmentation des coûts de construction
le poids des normes la raréfaction du
foncier et bien sûr la hausse des taux
d'intérêt empêche de nombreux ménages
d'acheter un bien c'est pourtant
l'espoir légitime de beaucoup cette
crise intervient alors que le stock de
logement est déjà très insuffisant il
est urgent aujourd'hui dans relancer la
construction et d'en faciliter d'en
faciliter l'accès vous faites exactement
l'inverse par exemple en excluant du
marché locatif les logements classés g
dès 2025 PUF e eu soit à terme 40 % du
marché locatif privé le ministre des
Finances a osé dire qu'il voulait
différer cette mesure totalement
irrationnelle en pleine crise il avait
raison il a dû rentrer dans le rang dès
le lendemain depuis 2017
qu mesur positiv avez-vous prise pour
encourager la construction de logement
madame la Première ministre une fois
n'est pas coutume écoutez les
républicains ne touchez pas au prêt à
taux zéro défiscaliser les intérêts pour
permettre aux Français d'emprunter de
pouvoir accéder à la propriété faciliter
les donations pour permettre aux jeunes
générations d'acquérir plus vite et plus
facilement leur résidence principale les
Français qui ne peuvent plus log sont en
colère les entreprises du bâtiment sont
aux abois que comptez-vous faire pour
désamorcer ce qui s'annonce déjà comme
une véritable bombe
sociale je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée an jeunev ce matin même
j'étais à l'ouverture du 83e congrès de
l'USH et cette crise du logement que
vous décrivez sur lequel le gouvernement
s'est exprimé et qui donnera l'occasion
à Patrice vergrit dans 48 he de se
rendre à ce même congrès pour répondre à
la famille du logement dans son ensemble
elle a déjà conduit à un certain nombre
de mesures malgré ce que vous dites le
plafonnement du taux du Livret à 3 % le
plan de rachat de 47000 logements
coordonnés entre la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation et Action Logement
la relance précisément du PTZ et
d'autres mesures sur lesquelles à ce
stade je ne prolongerai pas le propos y
compris parce qu'il y aura d'autres
questions pendant cette même séance mais
vous évoquez vous évoquez un sujet celui
des passoirs énergétiques et la question
potentielle de la sortie du parc d'une
partie des locations je me réjouis de
cette occasion d'abord de rappeler les
choses il n'y a aucun texte en France
qui dit et qui prévoit qu'à compter
d'une date on va sortir des locataires
d'un logement il y a un texte qui
rappelle qu'il y a une obligation de
travaux et que si les travaux ne sont
pas faits à cette date ensuite à la fin
du bail quand il y a un changement de
locataire si les travaux n'ont pas été
faits à ce moment-là il faut les faire
avant de pouvoir réaccueillir un nouveau
locataire je ne veux pas croire ici que
vous plaidiez sincèrement en braquant
les projecteurs sur les propriétaires
qui pourra avoir des difficultés pour
faire des travaux sans garder de la même
manière avec la même intensité les
locataires qui ont du mal à payer leur
factur comp tenu du fait qu'on est dans
des passoirs énergétiques il y a un
travail de simplification des DPE à
faire un bilan des G+ sur lequel nous
allons aller mais à laisser penser que
c'est en minorant nos ambitions
climatiques qu'on accélérera la sortie
du logement on trompe doublement les
Français je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre madame
jeunevard merci madame la Présidente
parlons de ma prime ruve monsieur
monsieur le ministre c'est la même qui
est censé faciliter une amélioration
énergétique des logements c'est un bazar
inommeable il y a pas une semain dans
nos permanences sans que nous soyons
interpellés sur le dysfonctionnement du
de ma prime r par exemple merci beaucoup
madame madame jeunevard vous n'avez plus
de temps je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Véronique Roton pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse àsieur ministre de
la Santé la prév Aurélien Rousseau
monsieur le ministre plus de 2 millions
de femmes sont atteintes d'endométriose
en France aujourd'hui oui 2 millions de
femmes dont le diagnostic est encore
tardif puisqu'il peut prendre jusqu'à 7
ans l'enjeu est donc de mieux
diagnostiquer mieux accompagner et
surtout soulager celles qui souffrent au
quotidien de cette maladie comme vous le
savez toutes et tous un texte au
portuniste arrivve dans un hémicycle on
aurait préféré voir leurs auteurs voter
la loi visant améliorer les conditions
de l'IVG voe la résolution visant à
reconnaître l'endométriose comme une
affection longue durée en bref
s'intéresser réellement à la santé des
femmes nous majorité travaillons pour la
santé des femmes avec conviction et
détermination depuis 2017 nous nous
associons bien évidemment aux actions
des différents comités féminins pour le
dépistage du cancer du sein sur
l'endométriose nous écoutons les femmes
et les associations formidables qui les
accomp
que disent-ell bien sûr la maladie rev
plusieurs formes parfois invalidantes
mais ces femmes malades ne souhaite en
rien être traité systématiquement de
victime ou de personnes porteuses de
handicap ce qu'elle souhaite c'est que
le diagnostique soit facilité que le
parcours de soins soit adapté que les
acteurs concernés soient bien formés et
que la maladie soit mieux connu monsieur
le ministre pourriez-vous nous faire un
point d'étape sur la façon dont vous
compte répondre aux besoins qu'expriment
les femmes atteintes d'endométriose et
nous dresser un premier bilan des
actions mises en œuvre réellement au
sein de la stratégie nationale de lutte
contre l'endométriose je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma chers collègu la
parole est à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau
ministre de la santé et de la
prévention madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Véronique rioton
l'endométriose est un problème de
société c'est un problème de santé
publique aujourd'hui une femme sur 10 en
est atteinte et cela nécessite une
réponse collective une réponse
collective qui n'a pas commencé il y a
quelques semaines mais qu' a commencé il
y a de nombreuses années sous
l'impulsion notamment des association à
qui je veux rendre hommage sous
l'impulsion de parlementaire dans cette
assemblée à qui je veux rendre hommage
Véronique louvagi Sébastien pay t vie ou
clémentintin par exemple et sous
l'engagement du gouvernement et de toute
cette majorité pour porter une stratégie
nationale sur
l'endométriose ce sont des actes ce ne
sont pas des récupérations de la 25e
heure et
donc demain
matin avec Sylvie retaillot et avec
beréranger Couillard nous nous
présiderons à Rennes le comité de
pilotage de cette stratégie sur les
trois grands axes d'abord
toujours toujours mieux faire connaître
cette maladie parce qu'aujourd'hui
encore il y en a certains qui
considèrent que c'est une maladie de
bonne femme non l'endométriose est un
sujet de santé publique deuxièmement
faire progresser la recherche pour que
la France soit aux avant-postes
troisièmement toujours et encore former
les professionnels faire connaître cette
maladie pour mettre un terme à
l'herrance diagnostique alors nous
devons aller encore plus loin j'ai signé
la semaine dernière une instruction pour
renforcer notamment la l'homogénéité des
prises en charge en l' affffection de
longue durée parce qu'elle existe cette
affection de longue durée elle a triplé
en 4 ans elle a été elle a augmenté de
50 % à un an et encore une fois je pense
que c'est un sujet de mobilisation
collective plutôt que d'appropriation de
la dernière minute merci je vous
remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame
Christine pirzbon pour le groupe
socialiste
merci madame la ministre des Solidarités
de la famille le 26 juillet dernier j'ai
remis à madame la Première ministre et à
vous-même un rapport sur le reste à
charge en NPAD et vous ai détaillé
plusieurs propositions pour baisser
celui-ci mais surtout remettre à plat
tout le système sur la base d'un constat
accablant c'est une évolution globale de
l'action publique dans le domaine de la
prise en charge des personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie qui doit être mise en
œuvre et nous sommes beaucoup dans cet
hémicycle à espérer encore la grande loi
grand âge promise au français depuis
plus de 20 ans vous le savez madame la
ministre depuis de longs mois les
éepades et les résidences autonomie
tirent la sonnette d'alarme des facteurs
conjoncturels sont venus s'ajouter à des
difficultés structurelles d à un modèle
économique
obsolète vous avez annoncé un premier
geste avec une enveloppe de 100 millions
d'euros pour les établissements et
services à domicile c'est une bonne
chose mais je peux d'ors et déjà vous
affirmer au vu des chiffres que j'ai vu
sur mon département que ce sera
insuffisant comptez-vous aller plus loin
si la consolidation des situations
confirment mes craintes par ailleurs je
reçois ces dernières semaines de
nombreux courriers de toute la France
tel ce monsieur hberger à Sartrouville
dans un épad public dans les Yvelines
qui a vu sa facture augmenter de 205 €
par mois ù ce puit des ce puis de mois
dans un épad hospitalier qui a vu sa
facture augmenté de 145 €. ce ne sont
pas des cas isolés malheureusement
j'indiiquer dans mon rapport que 76 %
des résidents ne sont pas en mesure de
payer leur reste à charge avec avec
leurs revenus mensuels combien
seront-ils à la fin de l'année alors ma
question est simple comment allez-vous
aider les 420000 résidents et leurs
familles confronté à des dépenses
insoutenables je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame AORE
berger ministre des Solidarités et des
familles merci madame la
présidente madame la députée Christine
pierb déjà merci merci pour le rapport
que vous nous avez remis à la première
ministre et à moi-même et pour
l'engagement sincère qui est le vôtre
sur ce sujet il y a plusieurs questions
que vous posez oui nous avons
immédiatement agi avec la première
ministre avec un fond vous l'avez dit de
100 millions d'euros sur ce qui n'est
pas normalement une compétence immédiate
de l'État vous le savez bien de manière
à venir en soutien à la fois des épades
qui sont dans des situations critiques
mais aussi des services d'aide à
domicile j'ai fait installer en lien
avec les ARS des commissions dans chaque
département qui ont vocation à réunir
les financeurs et les créanciers ce qui
ne s'était jamais fait j'ai d'ailleurs
donné un instruction que les
parlementaires soient directement tenus
informés justement de la composition et
de la mise en œuvre de ces commissions
départementales qui ont été installées
d'ici la fin septembre ça c'est la
première réponse qui est celle de
l'urgence ensuite il y a des enjeux qui
sont à la fois des enjeux conjoncturels
des épats dont on sait qu'ils ont besoin
de ce soutien rapide et que l'État est
prêt à mettre en œuvre et puis des
sujets plus structurels que vous avez
évoqué sur le modèle économique de nos
épad parce que je crois qu'il faut
assumer qu'on est enfin un vrai parcours
résidentiel au bénéfice des personnes
âgées qu' puisse rester vieillir à
domicile ce qui est en général leur
première demande qu'ell puisse avoir un
vrai parcours d'autonomie dans des
résidences qui soient adaptées et qu'on
est enfin des épades en dernier recours
de plus en plus médicalisé notamment sur
la question des maladies
neurodégénératives stratégie que nous
avons initié avec le ministre de la
Santé et avec le ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche enfin nous allons reprendre le
20 novembre une loi qui est importante
et qui était tellement importante
qu'elle était attendue par les
parlementaires qui la demandaient et je
crois que vous aurez dans cette loi un
certain nombre de réponses madame la
députée je vous remercie madame la
ministre madame Thesse bon
oui merci je crois qu'on doit avancer
dès le PLF et dès le PLFSS notamment
pour mettre fin à une une inéquité qui
est que vous avez une réduction d'impôts
qui profite à quelques un nous devons
passer à une un crédit d'impôt qui
profitera à tous et qui baissera le
reste àchat
bravo je vous remercie madame la
ministre et nous avançons bien madame
député despl FSS puisque nous allons
permettre la fusion des sections soins
et dépendan qui est une demande
extrêmement importante pour les
départements pilotes et je crois que
c'est la démonstration que l'État sera
et est au rendez-vous je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur David riman pour
le groupe
GDR merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre des
Transports monsieur le ministre Gustave
fauert disait que voyager en modeste car
l'on voit mieux la place minuscule que
l'on occupe dans le le monde en guyan
des milliers de familles des dizaines de
milliers de personnes sont croisonnées à
domicile empêché de tout déplacement
livré à elle-même et croyez-moi quand je
vous dis qu'elles n'ont jamais été aussi
conscientes de la place minuscule
qu'elles occupent dans ce pays que l'on
dit un et indivisible les enseignants
partent les écoles se vident les les
prix explosent les gens meurent en
tentant les voyages par pyogue à une
période de l'année qui ne le permet pas
d'autres prennent l'avion au Surinam
dans un pays étranger pour se rendre à
Cayenne sur le sol guyanais la
liquidation d'erguyan annoncé il y a
quelques jours la preuve ultime s'il en
fallait une de l'échec phénoménal de la
politique non seulement de
désenclavement mais plus largement de
développement de la Guyane à partir de
quand est-ce que la population
aujourd'hui bloquée pourra se déplacer à
nouveau librement monsieur le ministre
je sais bien que vous allez me rétorquer
que la continuité territoriale en
matière de trajet intérieur relève de la
compétence de l'exécutif local or
suivrez-vous les recommandations du
rapport sénatorial du 30 mars 2023 qui
préconise de porter la participation de
l'État minima à 50 % sur la ligne
dépourvue de liaison routière car 500
ans de présence française en guyan ce
sont 500 km de route qui ont été
construit 1 km par an de route sur un
territoire de 90000 km² Monsieur le
Ministre êtes-vous prêt à engager des
discussions sur l'élaboration d'un plan
plannel de désenclavement de la Guyane
avant la fin de l'année 2023 les
Guyanais n'attendent pas de père Noël
ils attendent des investissements
publics pour pouvoir exercer leur
liberté fondamentale d'aller et venir je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est à monsieur Clément B ministre chargé
des
transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président riman vous appelez mon
attention et celle du gouvernement
puisque je suis ce dossier avec Philippe
Vigi notamment sur le cas extrêmement
préoccupant en effet de la liquidation
de la compagnie k vous soullignez plus
largement la question du désenclavement
je veux le dire la situation qui est
celle de la compagnie k aujourd'hui
n'est pas l'échec d'une politique
soutenue par l'État nous sommes au
rendez-vous et nous serons rendez-vous
sur la continuité territoriale nous
serons rende rendez-vous notamment sur
la continuité en terme d'infrastructure
je m'en suis entretenu ce matin même
avec le président Serville qui est à
Paris la décision qui a été prise que je
regrette c'est la succession à d'erreur
de gestion d'une compagnie qui dessert
massivement la Guyane et les Antilles la
décision est tombée il y a quelques
jours nous avons nous avons pu échanger
le jour même de cette décision à votre
demande et c'était bien normal parce que
elle a des conséquences extrêmement
sérieuses en terme d'emploi puisque ce
sont 76 emplois qui sont mis en danger
en Guyane et en terme c'est sans doute
encore plus important de connexion
essentielle au sein du territoire nous
prendrons toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour assurer jour après jour cette
continuité avec différentes mesures très
concrètes que nous déployons avec
Philippe Vigier d'abord demain un avion
de la compagnie chaler sera présent en
Guyane pour assurer les mesures les plus
urgentes les connexions essentielles
comme les évacuations sanitaires comme
l'approvisionnement de médicaments je le
disais j'en ai parlé ce matin avec
Gabriel Serville nous sommes mobilisés
là-dessus ensuite dans les tro semaines
qui viennent nous mettrons en place une
délégation de service public d'urgence
elle relève en effet de la collectivité
territoriale de Guyane mais nous
l'accompagnons techniquement pour mettre
en place cette délégation de service
public et qu'il n'y ait aucune rupture
et puis nous préparerons immédiatement
aussi une délégation de service public
plus structurée pérenne l'État a
toujours été au rendez-vous pour
accompagner de cette délégation même si
elle relève en premier lieu de la
collectivité y compris financièrement
j'ai pris l'engagement que cet
accompagnement continuerait je reverrai
monsieur Serville avec Philippe Vigi
dans les jours qui viennent je suis à
votre disposition pour continuer ces
échanges nous laisserons pas tomber la
Guyane et nous laisserons tomber aucune
connexion essentielle dans les semaines
dans les mois dans les années qui
viennent merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur
riman merci de la réponse le ministre
mais il faut savoir que sur la question
de faire un plan de pannuel
d'investissement pour désencaver le
territoire vous n'avez pas répondu
aujourd'hui je rappelle encore les
chiffres la Guane c'est 90000 km² 500 km
de route nationale il y a rien d'autre
il y a urgence à dés le territoire à
permettre aux gens de se déplacer sur le
territoire guyanais donc je vous
redemande encore une fois il faut ouvrir
la discussion pour un plan pirénelavant
du territoire guanais je vous remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à monsieur
le Président bourlange pour le groupe
démocrate madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues le
nettoyage ethnique du haut carabach et
ces dizaines de milliers de victimes ne
sont que le premier acte d'une tragédie
qui si les appels de la France ne sont
pas entendus en comportera deux autres
la destruction à l'instigation de la
Russie de la démocratie libérale
arménienne et la remise en cause de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale d'une Arménie prise en
tenaille par les adeptes du
panturquisme il faut agir je vous pose
madame trois questions pour agir
première question le gouvernement est-il
prêt à saisir à nouveau le Conseil de
sécurité sur les décisions propres à
assurer la protection des minorités
arméniennes demeurer au carabach ainsi
qu'à protéger à garantir l'intégrité
territoriale et la souveraineté de la
République de l'Arménie la question des
sanctions doit être légitimement posé
2uxè question au-delà de l'aide
humanitaire d'urgence le gouvernement n
n'estime-t-il pas nécessaire de mettre
en place au niveau de l'Union européenne
un véritable plan marshal de
réinstallation des réfugé afin d'offrir
un avenir à ceux qui ont tout perdu et
de faire baisser en Arménie
même une tension susceptible d'emporter
la démocratie 3è question que
comptez-vous faire pour aider
militairement l'Arménie à se défendre
entendez-vous répondre rapidement à sa
demande d'armes l'Union européenne a
jusqu'à présent refuser à l'Arménie la
facilité européenne pour la paix ce
refus peut-il enfin être levé l'honneur
de l'Europe est engagé dans cette
tragédie si nous oublions heréan nous
oublions ce que nous sommes et ce que
nous devons rester assez d'indifférence
assez de complaisance assez de l'acheté
l'Arménie doit
vivre
merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Jean-Louis bourlange avant
toute chose mes pensées vont aux
arméniennes et aux
Arméniens au moment où je vous parle
plus de 100000 d'entre eux ont dû fuir
le haut cararabach fuir leur terre et
leur foyer c'est la quasi-totalité des
habitants de cette région c'est un
véritable exode massif et
organisé monsieur le Président bourlange
comme vous le soullignez cette situation
est d'une extrême gravité après 9 mois
d'un blocus illégal nous faisons face à
une offensive militaire de l'Azerbaïdjan
en violation du cesser le feu sous le
regard complice de la Russie qui a rompu
tous ses
engagements je le dis devant vous nous
condamnons fermement ces actions de
l'Azerbaïdjan très vite la France a pris
ses responsabilités aujourd'hui même la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colona est en
Arménie pour voir comment renforcer
notre coopération dans tous les domaines
et dire notre solidarité au peuple
arménien nous sommes mobilisés au plan
humanitaire notre aide a triplé pour
atteindre 12,5 millions d'euros depuis
le début de l'année une aide médicale
d'urgence est arrivée en Arménie ces
derniers jours et à ce soutien s'ajoute
les efforts des collectivités
territoriales et de la société civile
que je veux saluer en parallèle à cette
réponse à l'urgence humanitaire la
France est engagée pour réaffirmer son S
ti sans faille à la souveraineté et à
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie
nous agissons au sein de l'Union
européenne l'Union intervient au plan
humanitaire et a activé le mécanisme de
protection civile européen nous sommes
engagé pour tirer toutes les
conséquences de cette offensive
militaire et pour bâtir un véritable
plan européen d'appui à une Arménie
indépendante souveraine et démocratique
nous continuons également à mobiliser le
conseil de de sécurité des Nations unies
et a appelé l'ensemble de ses membres à
prendre leurs responsabilités une
mission de l'ONU est actuellement au
haut carabach pour évaluer les besoins
humanitaires monsieur le Président
bourlange la situation est grave nous
condamnons l'offensive de l'Azerbaïdjan
nous sommes solidaires du peuple
arménien et nous soutenons la
souveraineté de l'Arménie la position de
la France est claire et nous
continuerons à la défendre aucune paix
durable ne pourra être atteinte dans le
sud
par la menace ou par la force je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Roger
chudau pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Éducation
nationale vous pouvez vous targuer
d'avoir réussi une rentrée politique
fracassante on vous a vu sur tous les
fronts la BAA le harcèlement bravo il
était temps au bout de 6 ans de mettre
fin à C scandale cela dit votre rentrée
scolaire est moins brillante car il ne
se passe pas un jour aujourd'hui sans
qu'il manque des professeurs dans 50 %
de nos établissements et le système
pacte de remplacement ne marche pas il
ne peut pas marcher et vous le savez
mais parlons maintenant de l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire du projet de politique
éducative que vous devriez présenter à
l'assemblée nationale quand on vous
parle de projet politique éducative vous
répondez l'école républicaine et son
propre projet soit c'est une belle
pirouette mais parlons-en que reste-t-il
de la promesse républicaine de
l'élévation du niveau de connaissance
quand 11 % de nos adolescents sont il
letttrés que la moitié des élèves de 6e
ne savent pas lire en en entré en 6e
justement et que le baccalauréat ne vaut
plus rien que reste-t-il de la promesse
d'assimilation républicaine lorsque les
collégiens mettent le feu à leur collège
que reste-t-il de la promesse
d'élévation pardon de mobilité sociale
d'ascenseur social de la de l'école de
la République par le mérite il n' reste
rien vous n'avez même pas prononcé en 2
mois le mot de REP réseau d'duc ucation
prioritaire 20 % de nos élèves donc si
vous voulez vous nous parlez ensuite d'
d'un choc des savoirs et pour illustrer
ce ce que serait un choc des savoirs
vous parlez d'une nouvelle 6e parlons-en
une demi-heure de français en plus une
demi-heure de mat en plus ce serait
résible si ça n'était pas tragique non
ça n'est pas sérieux sincèrement il n'y
a pas de choc des savoirs il y'y a pas
de politique éducative à l'heure
actuelle nous avons changé de ministre
nous avion un ministre quasi mutique
maintenant nous avons un hyperlocas
c'est très bien sauf que vous vous ne
faites que poser des pansements le Grand
Corps Malade que l'éducation nationale
vous n'avez pas de pensée stratégique ma
question est donc la suivante quand
est-ce que vous présenterez un projet
pédagogique un projet éducatif de
l'école de la nation je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Gabriel Atal ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député chudau vous avez
commencé votre question en faisant
référence à la rentrée scolaire et je
veux en démarrant ma réponse vous n'avez
pas jugé bon de le faire rendre hommage
à tous les enseignants chefs
d'établissement personnel de l'éducation
nationale qui se sont mobilisés en cette
rentrée pour nos élèves vous avez
ensuite s'il vous plaît un peu de
silence vous avez ensuite monsieur chudo
qualifié l'éducation nationale de Grand
Corps Malade je rappelle que vous avez
été membre de l'inspection général
directeur de l'encadrement du ministère
conseiller au cabinet de Gill de
robobien conseiller 5 ans de François
Fillon pour l'éducation si le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale est un grand
corps malade il me semble que vous avez
aussi une part de responsabilité dans la
situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et oui l'étiquette RN
l'étiquette RN ne suffit pas à se faire
passer pour un
antiystème enfin je veux vous dire que
oui mon ambition et notre ambition est
bel et bien d'élever le niveau de nos
élèves et à ce titre nous avons un grand
motif de fierté depuis 2017 le
dédoublement des classes en Rep et en
Rep plus qui permet à près de 500000
élèves aujourd'hui de faire leur rentrer
dans une classe à 12 et nous constatons
d'ors et déjà que les écarts en français
et en mathématiques se sont
drastiquement réduit depuis que nous
avons mis en place cette politique
évidemment qu'il faut poursuivre
évidemment qu'il faut qu'il faut
continuer c'est la raison pour laquelle
je l'ai dit je seraiis amené à annoncer
des initiatives supplémentaires
s'agissant de l'élévation du niveau en
français et en mathématique notamment
mais d'ors et déjà les annonces que j'ai
eu l'occasion de faire sur le calendrier
du baccalauréat pour enfin reconquérir
le mois de juin ça fait des années qu'on
en parle le nouveau calendrier nous
permettra de garder les élèves au
collège et au lycée jusqu'à la fin du
mois de juin c'est déjà une partie
l'élévation du niveau ensuite nous
aurons apporté des initiatives
supplémentaires je ferai des annonces ce
jeudi en la matière et j'avancerai avec
la représentation nationale sur cet
enjeu dans les mois qui viennent je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député oui quelques
instants monsieur le ministre vous
mettez en cause un fonctionnaire sur
l'état de délicessence du système
éducatif vous vous trompez ceux qui sont
responsables du désastre ce sont les
politiques je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Sandrine
Rousseau pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres
mèes laissez-moi vous proposer un
exercice de fiction imaginez la ville de
Strasbourg 270000 habitants à peu près
privé d'eau 2 jours sur 3IS imaginez que
lorsque l'eau coule en fin du robinet
elle soit maronnasse qu'elle donne la
diarhée imaginez que des enfants
n'aillent plus à l'école faute d'eau
imaginez-vous dans l'impossibilité de
vous laver 2 jours sur trois et pour
boire les habitants de cette ville
doivent acheter des packs d'eau entre 6
et 10 € qui font l'objet de spéculation
et peuvent se revendre encore plus cher
tout cela se passe à Mayotte et c'est
loin Mayotte très loin pourtant Mayotte
c'est la France bien sûr on peut dire
qu'il s'agit d'une sécheresse
exceptionnelle mais ce serait voir
qu'une partie du problème ce dont il
s'agit ici c'est bien d'une crise de
l'abandon par l'État faute d'entretien
40 % des fuites d'eau du réseau pas de
traitement des déchets ni de lutte
contre la pollution aucune démarche
d'association des populations locales
pour trouver une solution pas
d'anticipation par les recherches la
situation n'est pas nouvelle 29 % des
résidences à Mayotte n'ont pas accès à
l'eau potable contre moins de 1 % dans
l'Hexagone sans eau tout est menacé bien
sûr le ministre des outresmèes a proposé
35 millions d'investissement d'urgence
1/ die du coût de l'autoroute
a69 quelques bouteilles d'eau 350
millions investis on ne sait pas quand
dépensements du dénis à la fin de
l'incompétence nous ne l'accepterions
pas une seconde dans l'exag
pourquoi l'acceptons-nous à Mayotte ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
pour le gouvernement les maorés sont-ils
des Français comme les
autres je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
ministre de l'Intérieur et
desre Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
madame la présidente madame Rousseau
imaginez une députée qui pe une question
Maillotte sans jamais s'y être rendu
madame la
députée sil vous plaît votre
intervention votre
intervention votre intervention est
particulièrement
démagogique de comparer les 50000
bouteilles d'eau que distribue l'armée
française en ce moment s'il vous plat
silence de comparer les difficultésat ma
quand nous défendion ici même laibilé
d'avoir un projet de loi spécifique que
votre groupe politique a toujours
combattu et de comparer les difficultés
que connaissent nos amis Maoris don
lequel le gouvernement fait des efforts
essentiels parce qu'il n'y a pas de Na
fréatique à maotte pour finalement
servir vos intérêts politiques et sans
vous être rendu auprès des
Maoris madame les député travaillez
plutôt avec nous pour fournir à la
population maoraaise sa véritable
autonomie en effet en eau elle qui
connaît sans doute la plus belle terre
de la République mais qui connaî
malheureusement le retrait et les enjeux
politiciens madame dont vous êtes
manifestement
l'incarnation je vous remerci monsieur
le ministre madame
Rousseau monsieur le ministre imaginez
un ministre qui parle de sécheresse sans
jamais avoir compris le réchauffement
climatique monsieur le
ministre madame la députée vous ne
voulez pas voir que l'un des problèmes
maot c'est sa surpopulation et que
lorsque nous nous battons pour des
opérations de reconduite à la frontière
lorsque nous nous battons pour la
scolarisation des enfants lorsque nous
nous battons pour construire un deuxè
centre hospitalier vous votez contre
toutes les décisions qui concernent
Mayot et aujourd'hui vous voulez nous
faire croire alors que les Maoris
réclament la fermeté de la République
que vous êtes de leur côté mais venez
dans 15 jour venez dans 2 mois venez
dans 3 mois nous allons tous les mois
avec le ministre desrot nous accompagner
sortez de Paris et allez à
mamouzou je vous remercie monsieur le
[Musique]
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Didier
leac pour le groupe
Renaissance merci merci madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Hervé
Berville secrétaire d'État à la mer et
j'associe avec moi de nombreux collègues
de tous les littoraux français monsieur
ministre la pêche est en crise ce n'est
pas la première fois certes mais cette
fois cette crise liée à la hausse du
carburant et à l'inflation menace toute
la filière en Bretagne notamment vous le
savez région qui représente la moitié de
la pêche débarquée en France tout le
monde est mobilisé vous avez d'ailleurs
reçu un courrier de l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques et politiques vous
faisant part de leur très grande
inquiétude un marapécheur de ma
circonscription me disait encore ce
matin si les bateaux s'arrêtent cette
fois c'est tout la filière qui risque de
s'arrêter je sais Monsieur le Ministre
que vous êtes mobilisé et vous avez
annoncé des mesures d'abord un plan de
verdissement du carburant maritime avec
une rision de 13 centimes par litre de
gazoil ensuite une nouvelle répartition
de la tax sur les éoliennes en mer en
faveur de la pêche ces annonces sont
bienvenues cependant il faut reconnaître
qu'elles ne prendront effet qu'à moyen
au long terme or ce qui est en jeu c'est
bien la survie de notre pêche la pêche
française l'une des plus respectueuses
des normes environnementales et sociales
l'une des plus contrôlées aussi ce qui
est en jeu aussi c'est bien la question
de notre souveraineté alimentaire je
rappelle qu'on apporte déjà les 2/ers
des produits de la mer que nous
consommons
oui notre flotte doit se moderniser et
oui notre filière doit mieux s'organiser
mais dans l'immédiat ce que nous vous
demandons c'est que la France pèse de
toutes ses forces auprès de l'Union
européenne afin de prolonger après le 15
octobre le dispositif Ukraine ainsi que
le relève des plafonds à minima
indispensable pour pouvoir investir
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre alors
nous faire un point détaillé cet
après-midi sur les actions que mène et
mènera le gouvernement pour soutenir sa
pêche merci merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur HERV
Berville ministre chargé de la mer merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Didier
LeGac le gouvernement a été et et
restera au côté de de nos pêcheurs
partout sur nos littoraux parce que nous
croyons en l'avenir de la filière et de
cette profession vous le savez vous le
savez face à cette situation et face au
fait que toutes les grandes crises de la
pêche sont des crises qui sont liées à
la hausse du carburant l'État a été
présent depuis plus d'un an c'est 75
millions d'euros qui ont été mobilisés
pour faire en sorte que les bateaux
continuent de sortir et mettre en œuvre
cette aide au carburant mais vous le
savez aussi et tout le monde était
parfaitement au courant le cadre
européen actuel à ce stade ne nous
permet pas de prolonger l'aide au
carburant au-delà du 15 octobre alors
face à cette urgence nous avons fait
trois choses premièrement nous avons
accéléré la mise en œuvre de mécanismees
de solidarité au sein de de la filière
et avec les acteur privé et c'est
notamment la mise en œuvre d'une ristour
de 13 centimes par Total et par d'autres
énergéticiens et puis surtout nous
poursuivons le combat que nous avons
mené pour prolonger l'aide au carburant
au niveau européen et nous allons le
faire dans les prochains un jour nous
allons le faire dans les prochains mois
pour faire en sorte de ne laisser
personne dans l'impasse et d'avoir cette
prolation de l'aide carburante et puis
nous allons aussi mettre territoire par
territoire avec notamment les préfets
des mécanismes avec les banques avec la
Direction générale des finances
publiques pour accompagner les
entreprises de pêche pour que personne
ne se trouve dans une situation
impossible et notamment de manque de
trésorerie donc vous le voyez l'ambition
qui est la notre c'est de renforcer la
souveraineté économique de notre pays et
puis à long terme aussi et nous avons
commencé tout de suite c'est de réduire
notre dépendance au carburant avec ce
plan de réduction de notre dépendance
aux énergies fossiles que j'ai annoncé
qui permettra la transition énergétique
des navires 450 millions d'euros issu de
la tax éolienne pour justement et bien
avoir des navire qui soit moins gourmand
en carburant c'est bon pour la planète
c'est bon pour la trésorerie et donc
c'est ce que nous allons porter ensemble
et je vous remercie également pour la
mobilisation de tous les députés du
Boulonnais Méditerrané en passant par la
Bretagne mon ministre merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Madame
sou pour le groupe la France
insoumise madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre de l'intérieur comme vous ne
pouvez l'ignorer Monsieur le Maire de
Grabels René Revol a été victime d'une
agression samedi 23 septembre dans une
rue de Montpellier des militants
d'extrême droite l'ont plaqué au mur
avant de lui dire on sait qui tu es
l'ami des Arabes tu perd rien pour
attendre nous étions nombreux à lui
témoigner notre soutien au cours d'une
manifestation organisée dans sa commune
je souhaite ici solennellement lui
renouveler notre solidarité est pleine
et entière au nom de mon groupe
parlementaire mais également je l'espère
au nom de l'Assemblée
nationale ces événements font suite à
plusieurs tentatives d'intimidation à
son encontre tout l'été René revvol n'a
pas cessé de recevoir un ras demaré
d'injure et de menace de mort suite à sa
prise de position contre la décision du
maire de bzier qui refusait au mépris de
la loi de marier une Française et un
Algérien la violence de l'extrême droite
n'est pas nouvelle je me souviens de mon
père à l'hôpital je me souviens des
miniierres tombales dans la boîte aux
lettres familiales mais l'agression de
René Révol s'inscrit dans un contexte
national inquiétant la peste brune se
répand multipliant les menaces
agressions ratonnade incendie et
tentative d'assassinat dans le silence
complice de votre gouvernement il fut un
temps où des femmes et des hommes
engagés sous des bannières différentes
se sont retrouvés autour d'un combat
commun contre le fascisme gloire à eux
et honte à vous monsieur le
ministre combien de drames vous
faudra-t-il pour comprendre la
dangerosité de l'extrême droite à quand
une réaction immédiate des autorités
lorsque celle-ci menace puis passe à
l'action le danger ce n'est pas la
gauche sociale et écologique que nous
incarnons le danger c'est l'extrême
droite sa conception de la République
biaisée son manque d'humanité et ses
projets
d'attentat je vous remercie la parole
est à Madame Dominique fort Ministre
chargée des collectivités territoriales
et de la
ruralité allez s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît allez s'il vous plaît seule madame
la ministre a la parole madame la
ministre merci Madame s' PLA chè
assz-ames et Messieurs assez-vous les
députés madame la députéea soudé vous
alors si vous vous n'assez pas je vous
rappelle à l'ordre madame la députée
vous att rappz à
l'ordre donc je viens de prononcer à
votre rencontre à rappel à l'ordre si
vous continuez ça sera laasstion
supérieure madame la ministre vous avez
la parole tout d'abord je tiens au nom
de la première ministre et au nom du
gouvernement à condamner cette agression
avec la plus grande fermeté j'apporte
nous apportons à Monsieur le maire René
Revol tout notre soutien et toute notre
solidarité je veux souligner ici le
travail exemplaire des services de
l'État et les en remercier René Revol a
été agressé le samedi 23 septembre à
Montpellier en marge de la manifestation
contre les violences policières dès le
dimanche 24 septembre il était contacté
par les services de police pour
l'inviter à porter plainte le lundi 25
septembre ce sont les forces de
gendarmerie sur sa commune qui se sont
déplacé pour l'entendre et pour lui
permettre de déposer sa plainte dans sa
mairie oui les services de l'État les
forces de sécurité intérieure les
préfets oui sont présents auprès des
élus locaux oui nous allons vers eux
élus
parlementaire gouvernement et service de
l'État devont marcher main dans la main
et je sais que dans cette hémicycle nous
sommes tous
solidaair de tous les élus victimes de
violence le 17 mai j'ai annoncé le PAC
sécurité le 7 juillet le plan de lutte
contre les violences faites aux élus le
Sénat va étudier la semaine prochaine
une proposition de loi visant à encore
mieux protéger les élus et qui comprend
notamment durcissement des sanctions
pénales à l'encontre des personnes se
rendant coupable de violence envers les
élus le gouvernement salue cette
initiative plusieurs députés parmi
lesquels violette spilbout Sébastien
Jumel travaille aussi sur ce sujet je
suis certaine que tous ces travaux
s'enrichiront les uns avec les
autres sur ces sujets plutôt que
l'invective plutôt que l'agressivité
c'est dans l'écoute le respect mutuel et
la solidarité que nous devons ensemble
merci Madame la
Ministre merci beaucoup madame la
ministre madame
sou alors ainsi c'est nous les violents
en attendant si vous n'agissez pas la
bête Simon que vous nourrissez par votre
discours finira par vous mordre la main
à vous
aussi je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Müller
pour le rassemblement
national
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie monsieur
le ministre alors qu'aujourd'hui le taux
de pauvreté chez les agriculteurs ne
fait comme augmenter au même rythme que
le taux de
suicide voilà que vous venez à leur
retirer un avantage d'une importance
capitale pour le monde agricole la niche
fiscale du gazol non
routier c'est selon vous une fisc
qualité qui incite à consommer de des
énergies fossiles vous voulez donc les
inciter à passer à l'énergie verte comme
si l'agriculteur de Dordogne qui a 500 €
pour vivre à la fin du mois avait les
moyens de faire ses
investissements vous nous expliquez
également que cela participerit à une
économie de 10 milliards d'euros mais au
prix de combien de fermes et de combien
de vies quand 200 exploitations mett
mettent la clé sous la porte chaque
semaine et que deux agriculteurs se
suicident par
jour milliard d'euros c'est la somme que
le président avait promis d'investir
dans la transition écologique et vous
avez été leschercher en grande parti
dans la poche de la profession la plus
pauvre de France quelle
honte si vous voulez faire des
économies la recette est là taxer les
super les super profits comme nous ne
cessons de vous le demander cessz de
soigner gratuitement avec l'argent des
Français ceux qui sont illégalement sur
notre
territoire et investissez l'argent
récupéré dans la survie de nos
agriculteurs c'est la moindre des choses
parce que là est ma question où sont les
mesures compensatoires pour la survie de
leur activité quand vous les amputez
d'un avantage économique
indispensable nous n'avons rien vu et
nous n'avons rien entendu entendu pardon
je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et
numérique président monieurs les députés
monsieur le député Serge mer où
êtes-vous aller pêcher ces 10 milliards
[Applaudissements]
d'euros Monsieur
müllersieur M vous pouvez reprendre la
parole si vous le
souhaitez vous navez aucune empathie
pour nos agriculteurs monsieur Gabriel
préconise des cours d'empathie
inscrivez-vous
d'urgence je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député müer vous
n'étiez pas encore élu député que
j'étais ministre de l'Agriculture
j'étais 3 ans le défenseur des paysans
et des
[Musique]
agriculteurs cesse de me battre pour eux
la différence entre vous et nous c'est
que nous nous voulons accompagner les
agriculteurs dans la transition
écologique et que nous le faisons
monsieur
Müller avec leur
accord la réduction de l'avantage fiscal
sur le GNR a été décidé pas contre les
agriculteurs avec les agriculteur avec
la FNSA avec les syndicats agricoles
dans le dialogue et dans la concertation
nous le faisons progressivement monsieur
Müller je ne sais pas une fois encore
vous êtes allé pêcher ces 10 milliards
d'euros 2,8 centimes par litre de
carburant voilà ce que nous allons faire
année après année nous le retirons pas
l'avantage fiscal nous leur laissons 35
centimes d'avantage fiscal par litre de
carburant à la fin de la trajectoire et
l'engagement que je prends monsieur
mulire moi qui pense aux agriculteurs
qui soutient les agriculteurs et qui les
aide dans le transition
c'est que l'intégralité des recettes
fiscales qui résulteront de cette
évolution de la fiscalité sur le GNR
toute la recette ira vers les
agriculteurs pour les agriculteurs pour
les accompagner de le transition
écologique et leur permettre de réussir
leur
transition je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
François joliv pour le groupe horizon
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre délégué en charge du log
monsieur le ministre la crise du
logement est un sujet désormais
politique le Congrès HLM qui vient de
s'ouvrir ce matin en témoigne
professionnel du secteur de l'habitat
pendant plus de 20 ans avant d'être
député je partage les inquiétudes des
acteurs du logement des élus locaux des
entreprises et bien sûr des habitants
qui cherchent un logement la côte
d'alerte est aujourd'hui selon moi
atteinte la filière immobilière est en
train de s'arrêter il lui faudra
beaucoup de temps pour redémarrer nous
faisons face à crise crise de la
production du logement d'œuf ils ne se
vendent plus déjà certains acteurs
d'immobilier entam et prépare des plans
sociaux conséquence de cette même crise
crise du marché locatif avec un
calendrier d'interdiction de mise en
location de logement ce n'est plus le
cas parce qu'en fait cette réforme a été
prévue en TS calme la transition
énergétique de l'habitat est une
nécessité mais ne rajoutons pas de la
crise à la crise crise du parc parcours
résidentiel enfin notre politique du
logement a fait le deuil de la mobilité
que ce soit dans le parc HLM ou dans le
parc privé la fluidité du marché de
l'immobilier doit être notre seul guide
dans cette période difficile c'est
pourquoi le projet de loi de finance
doit absolument amorcer la sortie de
crise par des mesures fortes urgentes et
exceptionnelles ce budget doit être un
plan de de sauvetage de relance et
d'espoir pour les habitants monsieur le
ministre quelle est votre feuille de
route je vous remercie mon cher collègue
le est à
monurat ministre délégué chargé du
logement madame Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
joliv vous m'interpelle sur la triple
crise que connaî aujourd'hui le logement
et le Gouvernement partage votre
diagnostic après 15 ans de forte Haus
des prix fonciers et
immobiliers la hausse des taux d'intérêt
l'augmentation du coût des matériaux a
effectivement largement déstabilisé le
modèle de production du logement et ce
au moment même où l'urgence
climatique nous commande une ambition
forte en matière de transition
écologique la
réponse du gouvernement doit être sur
les deux
ambitions nous ne pouvons pas d'un côté
répondre à l'urgence environnementale en
sacrifiant l'urgence sociale ou
l'inverse il faut tenir les deux
exigences la transition écologique n'est
pas une option mais l'accès à un
logement abordable et descent non
plus pour se faire le gouvernement a
déjà enclenché un certain nombre de
mesures Christophe Béchu évoqué tout à
l'heure le maintien du taux du livra à 3
% qui correspond à 1,4 milliard en terme
d'apport aux bailleurs sociaux mais il
aurait pu ajouter les 250 millions de
quasi fonds propres pour les bailleurs
sociaux il aurait pu ajouter les 700
millions d'apport du gouvernement pour
accompagner la rénovation énergétique il
aurait pu ajouter le maintien du prêt à
tau zéro sur l'ensemble du territoire
national pour l'accession sociale il
aurait pu ajouter le renforcement du
logement locatif
intermédiaire élargi d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui à 209 commun supplémentaire
mais nous continuerons à travailler sur
d'autres mesures avec Bruno Le Maire sur
le crédit bancaire et un élargissement
et également avec les bailleurs sociaux
et un nouveau P merci Monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur loï
prudom pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre pH alors que la
Commission européenne souhaite
réautoriser le glyphosate pour 10 ans
vous déclariez le 12 septembre dernier
dans Ouest France je vous cite on fait
confiance à la science aux études qui
disent que le glyphosate ne pose pas de
problème cancérogène monsieur le
ministre à quelle science faites-vous
confiance la science de baayère celle
qui escamote les études qui lui
déplaisent à celle de l'EFSA l'agence
sanitaire européenne qui ignore 90 % de
la littérature scientifique et ne prend
en compte qu'une poignée d'études
partiale fournie par les industriels et
écarte la majorité des études
académiques car ces études académiques
avec celle de l'incerme de l'inraé de
l'ifréè ou encore du CIRC conclut au
caractère cancérogène
génotoxique neurotoxique
reprotoxique perturbateur endocrinien du
glyphosate
elle pointe aussi ses impacts sur
l'environnement et la biodiversité vous
le voyez la science indépendante est
unanime sur les dangers du glyphosate et
j'aurais la faiblesse de croire qu'en
ayant rien à vendre elle est plus
crédible en 2017 Emmanuel Macron lui
aussi en était convaincu et avait même
promis d'interdire le glyphosate dans
les 3 ans son renoncement a des
conséquences très concrètes j'en veux
pour preuve la multiplication de
clusters de cancer pédiatrique et les
plus de 600 demandes de reconnaissance
en maladie professionnelle
d'agriculteurs porté par l'association
phyov viictime rien qu'en
2022 monsieur le ministre ne me dites
pas qu'il n'est pas possible d'interdire
le glyphosate faute d'alternative plus
de 50000 agriculteurs bio s'en passe
depuis des décennies voilà baayur
Monsanto a quelque chose à vendre mais
vous monsieur F personne ne pourrait
croire ici et dans le pays que vous
allez brader la santé des agriculteurs
des Français et des écosystèmes pour les
profits d'une
multinationale alors Monsieur le
Ministre pouvez-vous nous rassurer et
nous confirmer ici que la France votera
contre la réautorisation du glyphosate
le 13 octobre prochain je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe vum ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député loï
prudom la vous l'avez dit la Commission
européenne a mis sur la table une
proposition de réhomologation quasiment
sans aucune condition pour 10 ans du
glyphosate la position de notre pays
elle est d'écouter les scientifiques et
en l'espèce nous avons du mal à croire
et à comprendre que la Commission
européenne n'écoute pas y compris ce que
dit l'autorité européenne des aliments
qui explique qu'il est souhaitable
d'approfondir une partie des choses en
terme d'impact y compris sur la
biodiversité depuis 2018 la position de
la France elle est d'interligre le
glyphosate dès lors qu'il y a des
alternatives de substitution et c'est ce
qui s'est passé pour la totalité des
usages non
agricoles vous le savez dans le proc
euréen si nous voulons nous opposer à la
position de la Commission européenne
nous devons réunir une majorité des 2
tiers je vous le dit de la façon la plus
claire qui soit la France ne soutient
pas la proposition européenne de
réhomologation sans condition du
glyphosate
elle travaille elle travaille à la
construction d'une majorité qui
évite les distorsions de concurrence
avec des situations
nationales on se retrouve dans une
situation où nous n'écoutons pas la
science
3 que ça représente un retour en arrière
je sais à quel point vous aimez que les
choses soient binaires mais entre les
deux entre les deux derrière l'apparence
de la radicalité et derrière la
simplicité il y a une grande part de
démagogie qui ne tient compte ni de la
nuance et pour le coup ni de la
science merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
neigelen pour le groupe yacht merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre nos entreprises françaises
subissent aujourd'hui une double peine
des prix de l'énergie qui restent
exorbitants et des concurrents
internationaux qui pour certains déjà
n'en sont pas frappés et qui en plus ont
des conditions sociales et fiscal bien
moinsisante les entreprises textiles
sont le parfait exemple tout d'abord je
me dois de vous rappeler que cette
filière compte encore plus de 62000
emplois en France et plus de 3000 dans
lesvoges après la récente liquidation de
l'entreprise FTV à solur et une perte
d'emploi pour ces 48 salariés pour qui
j'ai une pensée en posant cette question
il est nécessaire pour le gouvernement
de comprendre les difficultés de nos
industries et particulièrement de cette
filière désormais dernier filateur
français en fibre courte situé au tio t
MP achète sa matière première au prix où
la concurrence internationale vend sa
matière filée concernant les tissur les
tisseur ils sont en face de concurrents
pakistanais qui ne sont pas impactés par
la hausse de l'énergie et qui vendent
leur tissu 60 % moins cher quant aux
ennoblisseurs en plus d'être frappé par
le prix du gaz ils sont les victimes de
contraintes environnementales que leurs
concurrents n'ont pas aussi vous
comprendrez que cet exemple n'est pas
unique mais qu'il est symbolique et
qu'il concerne aussi bien d'autres
industrie voir l'agriculture deux
questions madame la Première ministre
quand allons-nous sortir de l'accord
européen qui indexe l'électricité sur le
prix du gaz et à l'heure où nous parlons
de la réindustrialis la
réindustrialisation française que
comptez-vous faire pour empêcher nos
savoir-faire historiques de fermer ou
d'être obligé de
s'expatrier merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Christophe
nigelen le gouvernement est
particulièrement mobilisé pour soutenir
l'industrie dans notre pays et je suis
convaincu qu'il y a place pour une
industrie textile compétitive en France
et je sais l'importance de ce secteur
dans votre département des vauges et
votre engagement pour le défendre
soutenir l'industrie c'est le sens de la
politique menée depuis 2017 avec la
réforme du marché du travail avec la
baisse des impôts de production avec le
soutien à l'innovation que ce soit au
travers de France relance du programme
territoire d'industrie ou aujourd'hui de
France 2030 alors j'entends les
difficultés que vous mentionnez je peux
vous assurer que le gouvernement est
mobilisé pour les régler une par une et
je vous invite à évoquer ces situations
avec le ministre de l'Industrie et le
ministre du Travail d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui des des usines rouvre et
que nous avons besoin de salariés
qualifiés de salariés formés c'est aussi
tout le sens de notre politique en
faveur de l'apprentissage et de la
Réforme que nous engageons des lycées
professionnels alors je sais aussi
combien la hausse des prix de l'énergie
a été difficile pour beaucoup de nos
entreprises notamment dans les secteurs
fortement consommateurs comme le textile
immédiatement nous avons pris des
mesures le bouclier tarifaire pour les
très petites entreprises l'amortisseur
électricité et les guichets d'aide pour
les entreprises les plus touchées au
total 25 milliards d'euros ont été
déployé pour aider les entreprises
l'état prenant en charge jusqu'à 40 % de
la hausse de leur facture d'énergie
aujourd'hui nous n'abordons pas l'hiver
dans de la même manière les prix sont
plus bas nos stocks de gaz sont remplis
à plus de 90 % et les équipes d'EDF sont
à pied d'œuvre pour assurer notre
production nucléaire et je veux saluer
leur engagement et leur
professionnalisme cependant certaines
entreprises continuent à avoir des
difficultés notamment celles qui ont ont
signé des contrats pluri-annuels avec
des prix de marché trop élevés elles
seront toujours protégées par
l'amortisseur électricité le projet dois
de finance prévoit à cet égard près de
800 millions d'euros pour continuer à
les soutenir plus largement nous sommes
en train de réformer le marché de
l'électricité au niveau européen comme
en France notre objectif est d'offrir
des prix compétitifs pour tous les
consommateurs français que chacun puisse
bénéficier de nos investissements dans
le nucléaire les discussions sont en
cours et devrait aboutir au cours du
mois d'octobre ces discussions devront
permettre de concilier à la fois
l'intérêt des Français et la
préservation des grands équilibres
financiers d'EDF acteur clé de la
transition énergétique depuis le début
nous avons affirmé un principe ne laissz
personne sur le côté et nous n'en
dévirons pas je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre
monsieur nelen merci madame la
Présidente merci madame la Première
ministre il est vrai qu'enfant nous
avons une une chance et notre parc
nucléaire nous devons impérativement
après les déboirs des années passées
s'en servir le remettre au centre du jeu
pour que nos industries puissent en
profiter merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur dinoer
pour le groupe les
républicains merci Madame la madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
avec mes collègues du groupe les
républicains nous souhaitons attirer
votre attention sur la révision d'un
texte européen relatif aux émissions
industrielles la directive IED à l'heure
où la France est engagée dans la dans la
phase des trilogue sur ce texte nous
souhaiterions connaître la position qui
sera défendue par les ministres français
ce texte qui vise à faire entrer les
élevages bovvin dans le champ d'une
directive relative aux émissions
industrielles alors qu'ils en étaient
jusqu'àors exclus représente un
véritable danger pour nos élevages et
nos
territoires les éleveurs les éleveurs de
bvin et notamment les éleveurs laitiers
du département de la Loire sont déjà
soumis à l'application de trois
directives concernant le traitement de
leur émission madame la Première
ministre les les exploitations laitières
françaises subissent des contraintes
économique et administrative lourd à
l'heure où ces filières sont confrontées
à un enjeu d'attractivité et de
renouvellement des générations il est
indispensable de les protéger en
maintenant leur exclusion de cette
directive si cette directive était
confirmée le surcout pour une
exploitation laitière d'une centaine de
vaches auiré entre 20000 et 27000 € un
tel surcout est intenable inacceptable
pour nos agriculteurs madame la Première
ministre allez-vous écoutez nos éleveurs
vos ministres vont-ils respecter le vote
des eurodéputés qui ont largement rejeté
l'entrée des beauvins dans le champ de
la directive en juillet
dernier je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Laurence bone secrétaire d'État
chargée de
l'Europe merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés merci
je je veux vous
rassurer d'abord parce que la France
connaît évidemment les difficultés des
agriculteurs et j'étais moi-même en haut
de Savoie avec les députés Antoine
Armand et Véronique rioton et j'ai pu
voir à quel point effectivement non
seulement cet élevage est important mais
aussi leur leur demande en matière de
réglementation
européenne je va vous rassurer parce que
la France agit dès que cette directive a
été proposée par la Commission pour
modifier les seuils qui s'appliqueraient
au beauovvin notre objectif est que ça
ne s'applique pas à plus à des pardon à
des exploitations qui auraient moins de
350 UGB qu'on en exclu les petites et
qu'on en exclut les exploitations
extensives comme vous savez nous sommes
en trilogue et nous allons continuer de
nous battre pour maintenir cette
position nous voulons absolument que
pour nos agriculteurs nous trouvions le
bon équilibre entre préserver la qualité
de notre élevage et préserver nos
objectifs climatiques et puis enfin
comme vous le savez aussi il y a une
chose à laquelle nous nous sommes
attachés depuis très longtemps c'est
d'avoir des clauses miroir pour
s'assurer que le bœf qui entre sur le
territoire européen satisfait aux mêmes
exigences que le bœuf européen lui-même
merci je vous remercie madame la
ministre monsieur signeri madame madame
la ministre je ne suis pas convaincu par
vos propos et nous serons vigilants dans
les semaines qui viennent et nous avec
les éleveurs avec les les éleveurs nous
n'attendons pas que des belles paroles
nous attendons des actes et je
solliciterai auprès du ministre de
l'Agriculture une rencontre de manière à
ce que nous puissions aller au-delà de
ces propositions merci très bien je vous
remercie monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel
Pellerin pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame Sylvie rotaillot
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur j'y
associe notre collègue constance
legrip madame la ministre je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur une
préoccupation urgente l'antisémitisme
persistant au sein de l'enseignement
supérieur français selon une enquête
récente du Parisien neu étudiants juifs
sur 10 déclarent avoir été victime d'au
moins un acte antisémite au cours de
leurs études que ce soit sur leur campus
en cours ou lors de soirées étudiante à
l'image de Jérémie dont l'histoire
déchirante a encore été révélée par Le
Parisien lors d'événement d'intégration
et de tournois sportifs à scienp
Strasbourg cet étudiant âgé de 23 ans a
été confronté à des champs nazis des
slogans antisémites et des agressions
verbales et
physiques selon Le Parisien ces actes
antisémite prennent la forme de
stéréotype ou de blague parfois même lié
à la Choa par exemple vive la Palestine
3945 le retour a été tagué sur un mur de
Paris 8 en scène Saint-Denis ceci
illustre le lien troublant mais de plus
en plus prignant entre l'antisémitisme
et certains discours politiques
d'extrême gauche qui s'insinuent dans
les campus universitaires et font
notamment des Juifs de France des
ambassadeurs de la politique du
gouvernement israélien l'enquête révèle
également que des préjugés à l'encontre
des étudiants juifs sont encore
largement répandus les juifs seraient
plus riches que la moyenne pour 24 % ils
détiendrai trop de pouvoir dans la
finance et les médias pour 18 % et dans
la politique pour 15 % enfin la culture
et les réseaux sociaux ne seraient pas
en reste à titre d'illustration
l'expression Dragon Céleste issu du
manga One Piece est insidieusement
exploité par certains étudiants comme
une métaphore antisémite sur les réseaux
sociaux cette utilisation détournée
d'une référence culturelle souigne
l'impérieuse nécessité d'une action
politique madame la ministre merci
beaucoup mon cher
collègue merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame Sylvie rotillot ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Monsieur et Madame les
députés Monsieur Le députémanuel Pin
tout d'abord je voudrais vous remercier
pour votre question qui me permet
d'aborder avec vous ici un sujet
un sujet qui doit tous évidemment nous
mobiliser c'est-à-dire vous l'avez dit
la lutte contre l'antisémitisme alors
c'est pour moi aussi l'occasion de
rappeler l'engagement total du
gouvernement pour enrayer ce fléo c'est
un fléo et qui vous l'avez dit
malheureusement agit aussi au niveau des
universités alors je veux être d'abord
clair évidemment comme vous
l'antisémitisme n'a sa place nulle part
en particulier pas dans l'enseignement
supérieur et il est inconcevable qu'un
étudiant puisse être un inquiété pour
ces convictions religieuses qu'elles soi
réell ou supposées et ce point est juste
inadmissible alors qu'il s'agisse
effectivement d'agression physique vous
l'avez dit ou parfois de faits qui sont
trop souvent minimisés vous avez parlé
de blagu ou de d'allusion non il n'y a
pas de petite plagues il n'y a que des
violences avérées et inadmissibles alors
pour mettre un coup d'arrêt nous nous
déployons actuellement un plan un plan
de lutte contre l'antisémitisme le
racisme et les discriminations
concrètement ce plan permet de repérer
je vous dirai comment de repérer ces
actes la première chose c'est
d'accompagnerner les victimes ce qui
permet de libérer la parole et de les
accompagner concrètement puis d'apporter
des réponses qui peuvent être de type
disciplinaire et ou judiciaire et le
président de l'université en a ce
pouvoir et puis vous avez parlé de tag
il est important d'agir complètement et
concrètement de réparer les dégâts du
type effaser les tags c'est important
pour permettre cela on forme les agents
on les sensibilise et on déploie des
référents antisémitisme racisme et
discrimination dans tous les
établissements donc c'est on est en
train d'essayer de mieux identifier ces
agents pour que les étudiants les
identifient pour mener cette lutte il
est important d'avoir l'engagement de T
beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Marietta
caramanli pour le groupe socialiste
merci Mame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Éducation madame la ministre première
ministre a annoncé des mesures en
matière de lutte contre l'harcèlement
des élèves à l'école mais Monsieur le
Ministre ma question porte elle sur
l'éducation etelle la prise en de
conscience d'autres mots qui menacent
nos enfants des dispositions
législatives existent l'article 312 16
du code de l'éducation dispose qu'une
information et une éducation à la
sexualité sont dispensé dans les
écolesétablissement raison d'au moins
trois séances annuelles et par groupe
d'âge homogène l'article 542 3 du même
code énonce qu'au moins une séance
annuelle d'information de
sensibilisation surous l'infance
maltraitée notamment sous les violences
intrafamiliales à caractère sexuel et
inscrit dans l'emploi du temps de tous
les élèves enfin l'article 31218 du code
dispose qu'une information et délivré
sur les conséquences de la consommation
de drogue et sur la santé dans les
collèges et lycées au moins une fois par
an par groupe d'âge homogène le seul
bilan quantitatif rendu public sur
l'éducation à la sexualité montré en
2022 que moins de 20 % des élèves y
avaient accès dans la forme prescrite
les moments de vis de classe sont
évidemment utiles à faire vivre ces
informations mais les enseignements les
enseignants estiment face qui sont moins
formés et la présence des personnels de
santé ou psychologue au sein des écoles
est contrainte par l'insuffisance de
moyens dédiés donc ma question est
simple monsieur le ministre qu moyen
réel en personnel en temps et en compét
non seulement pour la détection mais
aussi la prise en charge allez vous
engager en faveur de la lutte contre ces
fléau et de tous ces
fléau je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Marietta Caram d'abord vous
l'avez dit et vous l'avez souligné
vous-même la pr ministre a présenté un
plan interministériel de lutte contre le
harcèlement et je pense que c'est
important de le noter c'est la première
fois que cet enjeu a été porté à ce
niveau-là ce qui nous pousse tous les
ministères évidemment à nous mettre à la
hauteur du défi et de l'enjeu que
constitue ce fléo du harcèlement
scolaire et vous avez raison sur ce
sujet il faut des mesures extrêmement
claires et je crois que c'est ce que
nous avons présenté dans tous les
domaines qui s'agissent de la prévention
de la détection ou de la réaction à ces
phénomène ça nécessite aussi des moyens
et nous avons eu l'occasion d'annoncer
la première ministre l'a fait des moyens
effectivement pour renforcer nos
rectorats pour être capable de mieux
prendre en charge avec humanité ces
situations mais aussi une ouverture sur
une réflexion sur la médecine scolaire
puisque vous l'avez dit sur beaucoup
d'enjeux on a besoin d'une médecine
scolaire de médecins Scola d'infirmiers
scolair on y travaille aussi avec mon
collègue Aurélien Rousseau il y a un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
prise ces dernières années notamment en
terme de rémunération avec des
réhaussements de grille avec l'ouverture
de la prime r pr plus à ces personnels
dans les territoires concernés mais on
voit qu'on a un enjeu aujourd'hui encore
d'attractivité pour pour voir les postes
qui sont ouverts parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de postes qui sont ouverts et
qui ne trouvent pas preneur à ce stade
c'est donc il faut être inventif et
imaginatif je pense sur les réponses
qu'on est capable d'apporter sur ces
enjeux mais vous avez raison ces enjeux
sont absolument essentiels à la fois sur
la lutte contre le harcèlement mais
aussi sur d'autres enjeux tels que ceux
que vous avez évoqué sur ce sujet-là sur
lequel vous m'avez interrogé ce dernier
sujet mon prédécesseur avec av avait
saisi le Conseil supérieur des
programmes sur cette question je
recevrai les propositions en la matière
et nous avancerons à ce moment-là quand
j'aurai les propositions qui me
viendront du CSP je vous remercie je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame caramoli oui madame la Présidente
effectivement les engagements nous en
recevons beaucoup des compre-rendus
précis quantifiés des retours sur
l'effectivité des mesures annoncé très
peu alors monsieur le ministre je
remercie d'abord de ces éléments que
vous venez d'apporter mais je peut
prendre un engagement parce que la
réponse elle n'est pas elle est pas
complète c'est de vous réinterroger pour
savoir si ces mesures jugai utile par la
représentation nationale sont mis en
œuvre merci Merci beaucoup ma cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Sébastien Jumel pour le groupe GDR merci
président monsieur le ministre la saison
de la coquie Saint-Jacques vient
d'ouvrir le prix du carburant pêche tu
tois le seuil de 1 € le litre il était
de 60 centimes il y a un an dans moins
de 15 jours le 15 octobre l'État met fin
à la ristourne de 20 centimes d'euros le
litre instauré pour accompagner la pêche
après la flambée de l'énergie liée à la
guerre en Ukraine la guerre n'est pas
finie le prix du combustible ne faiblit
pas et l'aide va s'arrêter c'est une
décision vous le savez lourde pour une
filière qui a essuyé plusieurs tempêtes
qui ont notamment fait mal aux
trésoreries je pense au covid au brexit
pour ne parler que de cela
pour que les Français comprennent bien
ce qui se passe pour la pêche je le dis
sans détour 20 centimes d'ê supprimé
pour certains armements ils jouent leur
vie le prix du poisson n'évolue pas
pendant que le gazoil représente plus de
35 % des charges de l'armement avec la
rentabilité des Maré plombé avec la
fiche de paye des marins pêcheurs plombé
devant l'inquiétude forte de la
profession vous avez annoncé quelques
mesures alternatives à l'aide au car
carurant vous venez de les rappeler mais
elles ne nous ont pas convaincu elles
n'ont pas convaincu les quai ce sont des
dispositions qui soit existe déjà les 7
% de
biocarburant dans le gasoil soit qui
sont applicables à moyen et long terme
je le dis la taxe sur l'éolien c'est du
vent et en tout cas ça ne fait pas la
maille pour tout de suite vu l'impact
économique du prix de l'énergie sur la
pêche la question urgente vitale est de
savoir si au au lendemain du 15 vous
allez accompagner concrètement nos
armements de pêche j'étais il y a
quelques jours à 5 porriieux chez vous à
diep également et au Tréport les marins
pêcheurs attendent des mesures qui sont
sur la table je pense notamment à la
proposition d'une taxe flottante qui
amortirait les vagues de hausse en
attendant la décarbonation je vous
remerci de votre réponse merci beaucoup
mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieurv Berville ministre chargé de la
mer merci Madame mesdames et messieurs
les députés monsieur le député Sébastien
Jumel ce n'est pas l'état qui met fin à
cette aide carburant c'est le cadre
européen dans lequel nous sommes qui ne
permet pas à l'heure actuelle à ce stade
de le prolonger mais comme vous le savez
moi je suis comme vous à la fois nous
soutenons les pêcheurs mais soutenons
nous posons et nous mettons des actes
derrière les paroles et depuis un an
monsieur le député sastian junel vous le
savez très bien la France est le seul
pays qui a soutenu à cette hauteur ns
mar partout sur les littoraux c'est
grâce à la France et sur demande de la
première ministre que nous avons
prolongé par quatre fois par quatre fois
l'IDE au carburant c'est grâce à la
France et à la demande de la première
ministre que nous avons prolongé aussi
et augmenté le plafond qui est passé de
30000 € à 330000 € alors je vous le dis
très clairement comme je l'ai dit au
député Didier LeGac et je remercie
vraiment l'implication aussi de tous les
députés depuis plus d'un an je pense
notamment à Liliana Tangui mais aussi
Lisane metteyer pour ne laisser aucun
marin pêcheur dans la passe et pour
continuer à mobiliser les pays européens
pour prolonger cette aide carburant
au-delà du 15 novembre nous avons déjà
fait les démarches depuis quelques
semaines nous allons poursuivre pour
faire en sorte et bien que nous ayons
cet accompagnement car vous avez raison
il y a une hausse du carburant qui coûte
et qui pèse sur les trésor des
entreprises et puis à côté de ça nous
devons absolument comme nous nous étions
engagés au moment du salon d'agriculture
travailler sur des mécanismes de
solidarité vous l'avez évoqué il y a un
certain nombre de choses sur la table et
cette ristourne de Total ce n'est pas
nous ce n'est pas nouveau c'est quelque
chose qui permettra à la pompe d'avoir
une réduction de 13 centimes et puis si
nous voulons aussi donner des
perspectives de l'espoir pour les jeunes
marins nous devons dire quelle est la
trajectoire de décarbonation de
réduction cette dépendance aux énergies
fossilees et donc c'estes 450 millions
d'euros ce n'est pas du vent dès cette
année dès l'année prochaine les premiers
parcs sont en route et nous pourrons
cette période engager les premiers
financements donc vous voyez nous
travaillons au niveau européen nous
travaillons au niveau des territoires
pour accompagner tous les pêcheurs et
nous allons lancer la décarbonation de
ce secteur je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre vous
n'avez plus le temps mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Fray
pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Aurélia Rousseau
ministre de la Santé monsieur le
ministre 11 % c'est le pourcentage de
foyer infesté par des punaises de lit
entre 2017 et 2022 d'après l'ANC disparu
depuis 1950 ces insectes sont de retour
dans le quotidien des Français avec une
prolifération qui doit nous interpeller
véritable fléo les punaises de lit
soulèvent une inquiétude extrêmement
forte au sein de l'opinion publique tant
il est difficile de s'en débarrasser en
raison d'une résistance aux insecticides
et du prix de l'intervention ce qui
accentue encore plus la situation de
précarité de ceux qui en sont victimes
véritable tabou les punaes de lit
suscitent la honte alors même que les
infestations ne présentent aucun lien
avec un éventuel manque d'hygiène ou
d'origine en parler est très difficile
et peut générer un sentiment de rejet
tous les ménages modestes comésés à la
la ville comme à la campagne peuvent
être confrontés à ce fléo sur le plan
sanitaire la problématique causée par
les punaes de lit est également réel si
certains indiquent à raison qu'elle ne
ne transmettent pas de maladie elles
peuvent pour autant être à l'origine de
conséquences dermatologique pouvant être
grave en outre la punesse de lit est un
désastre pour la santé mentale de ces
victimes on ne compte plus les cas
d'anxiété de trouble du sommeil ou de
dépression à la suite d'une infestation
notre majorité est mobilisée D 2020 un
numéro d'appel a été mis en place qui a
permis de renseigner plusieurs milliers
de Français et en 2022 un plan
interministériel a été dévoilé pour
accentuer la l la lutte contre ce fléo
aussi monsieur le ministre dans la
continuité des mesures déjà initiées
quel nouvelle réponse le gouvernement
peut-il apporter sur le plan sanitaire
et économique dans cette situation qui
préoccupe fortement les Français je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien rousse ministre de la santé et
de la
prévention madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député comme la première ministre l'a
dit tout à l'heure et comme votre
question le send oui être infesté par
des punaises de par des PUL de lit est
un calvaire un calvaire quotidien et les
Français de plus en plus nombreux le
vivent dois dire aussi que c'est une
réalité que l'on croise dans de très
nombreux pays et notamment c'est des
cons sans aucun doute aujourd'hui du
réchauffement climatique alors notre
responsabilité elle est de cinq ordres
et le gouvernement la met en œuvre la
première d'entre elles c'est de mettre à
disposition de nos concitoyens une
information fiable claire et précise qui
ne soit pas uniquement qui ne repose pas
uniquement sur le recours aux pesticides
alors même que cela crée de la
résistance de la résistance chez ces
insectes notre deuxème responsabilité
monsieur monsieur le député c'est en
effet de poursuivre la recherche sur ce
sur ces nuisibles et l'anè est largement
mobilisé pour savoir quels traitements
sont les plus à même d'y répondre notre
troisième responsabilité c'est il y aura
dans les toutes prochaines heures une
réunion autour d'agès firmain lebaudau
et de Patrice vergrit c'est d'avoir tous
les acteurs qui sont regroupés les
bailleurs sociaux les entreprises les
représentants des locataires et des
propriétaires pour engager ensemble ce
combat et le dernier point et j'y tiens
particulièrement c'est celui qui
consiste à ce que nos concitoyens ne
tombent pas dans le piège de certains
qui voulant profiter de leur détresse
peuvent faire quelques profit sur leur
dos donc oui vous trouverez et nos
concitoyens trouveront sur le site du
gouvernement une liste de 480
entreprises qui sont référencées et nous
allons conduire avec les équipes du
ministère de l'économie et la
mobilisation de la DGCCRF euh une action
très résolue pour qu'il n'y ait pas des
voyou pour dire le mot qui profitent de
la détresse de nos concitoyens
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame
Alexandra Martin pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Éducation
nationale depuis votre nomination vous
avez fait preuve d'une volonté certaine
de combattre le fléo sociétal qui est le
harcèlement scolaire il est vrai que la
France a accuse un très grand retard
dans ce domaine contrairement à de
nombreux pays européens vos annonces
pour certaines que je défends depuis
longtemps devront être décliné
rapidement et en action concrète en
espérant qu'il ne s'agisse pas encore
d'ffits de communication nous avons créé
au sein des républicains un groupe
d'études consacré à la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire que je coanime avec
ma collègue Michel Tabarot nous serons
donc très vigilants sur la mise en œuvre
des propositions que vous avez formulé
nous avons également demandé la mise en
place d'une commission d'enquête
parlementaire par la voix de ma collègue
Christelle d'intorni la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire pour être efficace
doit être appréhendée dans toutes ses
dimensions et aussi dans le temps long
nous connaissons votre intérêt inspiré
par la méthode danoise pour la mise en
place de cours d'empathie je veux
prendre ici un autre modèle celui de la
Suède où ce ne sont pas que des cours
d'empathie qui permettent de résoudre le
problème mais la façon de concevoir
l'éducation des enfants de façon
positive motivante et bienveillante si
nous sommes biologiquement programmés
pour faire preuve d'empathie celle-ci
doit pouvoir se développer et
s'entretenir tout au long du parcours
éducatif et aussi au sein de la famille
pour cela il est absolument nécessaire
également de soutenir et d'accompagner
les établissements qui sont souvent sans
ressources et doivent per la pénurie de
psychologues d'infirmièr de surveillants
nous devons aussi leur permettre
d'élaborer un plan de lutte adapté aux
enjeux et aux spécificités de leurs
établissements n'est-ce pas un véritable
changement de paradigme que nous
appelons de nos vœux au sein des
républicains qu'il faut entreprendre un
changement systémique culturel qui
serait aussi propice à faire baisser le
phénomène croissant de violence chez les
jeunes dans la rue sur les réseaux
sociaux et tout simplement à apprendre
aux adultes de demain le civisme
merci je vous remercie ma chè collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Atal
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Alexandra Martin je veux
commencer par vous remercier parce que
moi je crois au dialogue et à la
capacité qu'on doit avoir à avancer
collectivement et largement et je pense
que s'il est un sujet sur lequel on peut
avancer en dépassant les clivage
politique c'est la lutte contre le
harcèlement et vous le savez pour
construire le plan que la première
ministre a présenté j'ai réuni des
représentants de chaque groupe
parlementaire vous en faisiez partie
pour l'ELR je vous en remercie il y
avait également madame Descamp pour
liotte Monsieur balanan pour le modem
madame Carel pour horizon monsieur
Marion pour Renaissance madame keloischi
pour le parti socialiste madame Pasquini
pour les verrs madame Bouris pour les
GDR monsieur Corbière pour la France
insoumise et Monsieur chudau pour le
rassemblement national je veux remercier
la représentation nationale de s'emparer
collectivement de ce sujet parce que la
réalité c'est que nous avons besoin
d'une mobilisation collective qui
dépasse d'ailleurs les enceintes de
cette hémicycle enceinte de l'école
c'est un sursaut collectif de la société
dont nous avons besoin j'ai parlé d'un
électrochoc et ce que nous pouvons
constater c'est que l'électrochoc a
démarré avec la libération de la parole
une multiplication par TR des
signalements de harcèlement sur le mois
de septembre 2023 par rapport à
septembre 2022 et maintenant notre
responsabilité à nous c'est d'être
capable d'y répondre et vous avez raison
d'être vigilante sur la déclinaison du
plan que nous avons eu l'occasion
d'annoncer s'il y a des jeunes qui
parlent et qui sont davantage à parler
c'est bien qu'ils ont l'espoir qu'on les
entende et qu'on agisse et oui nous
allons agir et c'est un véritable
changement de paradigme je vous rejoins
sur la question de la prévention avec
effectivement cette capacité à à
développer dès les premières classes
cette éducation bienveillante d'empathie
il faut en revenir à Jean-Jacques
Rousseau qui disait il y a l'instruction
de l'esprit et l'éducation du cœur et
oui nous ne devons jamais perdre de vue
que c'est la responsabilité de l'école
que d'apporter ça à nos élèves et le
changement de paradigme c'est aussi de
faire en sorte que la peur change de
camp et moi je l'assume totalement et ce
plan il nous permet de dire au
harceleurs qui empoisonne la vie de
centaines de millions d'élèves que nous
ne laisserons rien passer et que nous
serons intraitable en matière de
sanction je pense que le changement de
paradigme il est aussi là et que c'est
important qu'on le réaffirme tous
ensemble merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas Thierry pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre après le
temps des discours sur la planification
écologique vient le temps des actes en
la matière votre gouvernement a
l'opportunité immédiate de prendre une
initiative historique pour le vivant mon
collègue loï prudom vous a questionné
dans quelques jours vous porterz la voie
de la France sur le renouvellement de
l'autorisation du glyphosate dans
l'Union européenne vous pourrez alors
concrétiser un engagement ancien que le
Président de la République n'a pas
réussi à tenir jusqu'alors en 2017 lors
du précédent vote des États-membres la
France avait voté contre la
réautorisation de glyphosate une
position louable qui n'a pas suffit à
emporter la décision car l'Allemagne
avait voté pour depuis Emmanuel Macron a
échoué à interdire le glyphosate sur le
seul territoire français en 2022 il
avait finalement déclaré c'est l'erreur
que j'ai commise en début de quinena il
faut agir sur ces sujets au niveau
européen madame la Première ministre les
conditions sont réunies pour concrétiser
cet engagement du Président au niveau
européen car sur le plan politique
l'Allemagne a changé de cap et annonce
qu'elle ne votera pas la réautorisation
le vote de la France va donc être
déterminant son vote va conditionner la
réautorisation du glyphosate sur le plan
sanitaire le doute n'a plus lieu d'être
le glyphosate est classé cancérogène
probable depuis 8 ans par l'OMS et les
plus prestigieux institut de recherche
français sur la biodiversité alors que
la France reconnaît que les effets du
glyphosate sont incontestable et elle a
même fait savoir à la commission ceux-ci
n'ont tout simplement pas été évalués
par l'EFSA la seule position qui vaille
est celle du refus de toute
réautorisation de glyphosate une
majorité se dessine sur cette position
la France peut sirallié la position
exprimée par Monsieur Béchu manque de
clarté la question est simple la
position de la France sera-t-elle la
même qu'en 2017 un vote contre tout
renouvellement de l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché du glyphosate merci pour
votre
réponse je vous remercie monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame
Sarah ministre chargé de la
biodiversité madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député Thierry aujourd'hui la
position de la Commission ne correspond
pas ne convient pas à la position
française la reconduction comme elle est
proposée c'est la facilité la politique
ce n'est pas la facilité qu'est-ce que
nous avons fait qu'est-ce que nous
souhaitons nous souhaitons d'ors et déjà
et c'est ce que nous avons fait ici en
France baisser la consommation de
glyphosate dans les 15 15 dernières
années en réalité 30 % du glyphosate 30
% de baisse sur les depuis 2017 c'est la
plus grande baisse depuis les 15
dernières années c'est bien cette
position là que nous allons défendre au
sein de l'Union européenne nous avons
interdit le glyphosate dans tous les
usage non agricole qui l'a fait c'est
nous dans les parcs dans dans les parcs
dans les parcs c'est la loi la baie en
2014 et aujourd'hui qui aujourd'hui qui
le porte bien sûr c'est un projet de loi
du sénateur mais aujourd'hui c'est quoi
c'est quoi la réalité c'est plus de
glyphosate en France dans nos parcs et
dans nos jardins pas de glyphosate non
agricole une baisse de l'utilisation du
glyphosate dans nos exploitation la
position de la France est très claire
accompagner les agriculteurs autant que
de possible pour pas rompre en réalité
une compétitivité nécessaire même au
sein de l'Union européenne aujourd'hui
la commission nous renvoie vers quoi
vers un risque de distorsion entre les
agriculteurs pourquoi parce qu'elle
appelle à la protection spécifique État
par État monsieur le député Thierry la
France sera au rendez-vous puisque c'est
la position française qui est la plus
plus ambieuse baisser la consommation du
glyphosate et c'est ce que nous
continuerons à
faire merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole oui monsieur le
député merci madame la Présidente je
constate simplement que en 2017 la
position de la France était extrêmement
claire aujourd'hui vous tergiversez et
il faut le il faut le dire vous faites
un revirement sur un sujet fondamental
sur la transition écologique merci
madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député il n'y a aucun
revirement la réalité est claire et la
position est claire un accompagnement de
nos agriculteurs pour tenir notre
compétitivité et s'appuyer sur la
science la science elle dit quoi les
préconisations pour la santé et sur la
biodiversité pour ça deux choses à
chaque fois qu'il y a une alternative on
interdit la France est mieux disante à
chaque fois que c'est nécessaire on
investit in Rae en on s'appuie sur bien
ces rapports là donc monsieur le député
une seule et unique boussole la science
et une ambition parce que oui la France
aujourd'hui au rendez-vous le glyphosate
beaucoup en parle nous on s'en occupe
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Didier
Le Maire pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers et chers collègues j'associe
l'ensemble de mes collègues horizon mais
également mon collègue Éric Pouget à ma
question destinée à Monsieur le Ministre
de l'économie
il y a à peine 3 mois le Parlement
adoptait à la quasi unanimité une loi
concernant le risque d'incendie
permettant d'une part l'exonération des
taxes sur les carburants mais également
la suppression du manus écologique pour
l'ensemble des véhicules des10 pour
l'ensemble de notre pays certaines
dispositions de l'article 12 du PLF 2024
2024 pardon inquièteent nos soldats du
feu et bon nombre de nos collègues
parlementaires à juste titre par la voie
du ministre casenav le gouvernement a
annoncé sa volonté de faire conserver
aux 10 les acquis votés à l'aités dès
lors pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît
confirmer devant la représentation
nationale que les 10 continueront de
bénéficier de ces dispositions qui leur
donnent des moyens
supplémentaires par ailleurs nous
travaillons actuellement dans le cadre
de la mission d'information sur les
capacités d'anticipation et d'adaptation
de notre modèle de protection et de
sécurité civile depuis quelques années
les crises de nature et d'ampleur se
succède dans notre pays or notre modèle
de sécurité civile repose sur un
ensemble de professionnels et de
volontaire il est depuis plusieurs
années en tension perpétuelle et il
s'essouffle on appuie sur notre
territoire les associations et leurs
bénévoles font un travail remarquable de
maillage social aussi j'aimerais savoir
si dans le PLF 2024 des mesures pour
soutenir et stabiliser notre modèle de
protection et de sécurité civile sont
envisageables et le cas échéant lesquels
je vous remercie je vous remercie mon
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Didier le
maire il y a 250000 sapeurs pompiers
dans ce pays avec des statuts divers et
vous l'aveais dit il y a quelques
semaines la représentation nationale a
joint le geste à la parole en votant à
l'unanimité une proposition de loi
permettant de les soutenir et je veux
saluer en cet instant à la fois le
député lamirau et la députée panonacle
qui ont été les rapporteurs de ce texte
et qui ont travaillé à faire en sorte
qu'il puisse être adopté à
l'unanimité il n'y aura pas dans le
projet de loi de finances et je le dis
en mon nom je le dis au nom de la
première ministre qui s'est exprimé il y
a quelques jours de la manière la plus
claire qui soit je le dis au nom du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
qui s'est exprimé mais aussi et je le
dis avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
puisque nous partageons avec Dominique
fort le suivi des services d'incendie et
de secours il n'y aura pas de remise en
cause des avantages concernant les
pompiers dans le projet de loi de
financeces ni sur la remise en cause du
tarif qu'il paye en matière de GNR ni en
mettant en place un malus sur les
véhicules de sécurité civile qui
seraient absurde cont tenu des
spécifications qui sont liées à
l'ensemble de leurs interventions il
faut de la cohérence c'est évidemment ce
que nous allons faire en corrigeant
cette coquille je le dis de façon très
très clair vous posez la question de
comment on fait pour conforter le modèle
du volontariat dans notre pays et là
c'est pas au députés que je m'adresse
c'est au Major de sapeur pompier
professionnel que vous avez été avant
d'entrer dans cet hémicycle vous savez à
quel point pour ça ce sont pas seulement
des textes c'est le suivi et
l'accompagnement avec les présidents de
département et je suis certain que des
députés de tout bord seront capables de
de regarder comment accompagner et
faciliter cet engagement volontaire qui
est une des fiertés de la
France merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
pierriic Bertelot pour le rassemblement
national merci Madame la la présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre déléguée chargée des petites et
moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme madame la
ministre les chambres des métiers et de
l'artisanat sont financé par une taxe
pour frais de chambre des métiers que
payent tous les artisan or votre
gouvernement a décidé de ne plus
reverser la totalité de sa taxe au CMA
les CMA ne coûtent rien à l'état elles
sont justement financées par les
artisans et les petites entreprises
eux-mêmes qui payent pour le
fonctionnement de cette structure
publique en prenant cette décision de
détourner en partie la taxe dite pour
frais de CMA l'état enlève sur la tête
de réseau de CMA France 60 millions
d'euros sur un mandat de 5 ans cette
décision de détourner cette taxe a des
conséquences des conséquences très
concrètes dans ma région des haut France
ce sont trois centres de formation dans
la ruralité qui vont fermer cela découle
de la taxe mais également de votre
décret du mois dernier prenant une
nouvelle prise en charge du coût des
contrats d'apprentissage pour certaines
formations cette npec amorce une baisse
de 10 %. au moment où l'on a le plus
besoin de formation où le gouvernement
prétend vouloir prendre soin des
artisans et de protéger leurs activités
il assène un double coup prês pour ces
chambres qui forment nos jeunes c'est
non seulement profondément cynique mais
cela aura des conséquences immédiates et
désastreuses c'est affaiblir encore
davantage les artisans qui auront encore
plus de mal à recruter et à péréniser
leur entreprise puisqu'il y aura moins
de formation dispensé par les CMA à
cause de votre décision aussi je vous
demande madame la ministre vous qui êtes
l'autorité de tutelle qu'est-ce que vous
comptez faire pour maintenir ces centres
de formation qui vont fermer à cause de
cette
mesure je vous remercie la parole est de
à Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre
délégué chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce de l'artisanat
et du
tourisme la présidente mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieurs le
député Bertelot nous sommes d'accord sur
un point
incontestablement les chambres des
métiers sont un pilier absolument
indispensable de notre vie économique
sur l'ensemble des territoires et un
partenaire de confiance pour toutes nos
entreprises à commencé par nos artisans
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi j'en profite
pour vous dire qu'ils ont été tout au
long de l'année à nos côté et vous le
savez notamment dans vos
circonscriptions dans toutes les
circonscriptions au côté des artisans
qui souffraient des prix de l'énergie et
ils ont accompagné des milliers
d'entreprises pour autant la situation
du pays et ça ne vous a pas échappé non
plus nous conduit à faire des choix
difficiles nous avons aujourd'hui une
situation en matière de finances
publiques qui doit absolument tous nous
mobiliser et c'est pourquoi nous avons
effectivement demandé un effort au CMA
tout le monde doit participer je les
reçois très régulièrement et je sais que
c'est difficile de faire autant avec un
peu moins mais je sais aussi leur
capacité et leur volonté de s'adapter je
veux quand même revenir sur ce que vous
avez dit concernant les coûts contrats
et les niveaux de prise en charge des
coûts contrats d'abord vous rappeler si
ça vous intéresse qu'elle est annoncée
depuis juin 2022 donc personne ne
découvre rien ça me semble important de
le rappeler je veux aussi être clair
cette baisse des coupts-c contrats et
évidemment madame la ministre grandjan
le le le précisera si besoin mais ne
fera pas baisser les niveaux de de de
prise en charge on a déjà euh accompagné
une première baisse l'an passé et il
était prévu qu'on continue cette baisse
ça n'a en rien misise à mal le nombre
d'apprentis monsieur on comptait 933000
apprentis et c'est en hausse de 12 % par
rapport à l'an dernier malgré la coupe
je veux quand même rappeler dans les
quelques secondes qui me reste malgré
l'effort demandé que je ne ni pas que
s'il y a un gouvernement qui a mis des
dizaines milliards d'euros s'il y a une
première ministre aujourd'hui ministre
du Travail précédemment qui a accompagné
pas moins de 15 milliards d'euros dans
un plan d'investissement pour les
compétences c'est ce gouvernement on ne
détruira pas ce qu'on a construit merci
madame la ministre monsieur le député
oui merci madame la ministre je constate
que le gouvernement n'est non seulement
pas du côté des CMA et des artisans mais
que pour détourner les taxes et faire
quelques économies et n'hésite pas à
sacrifier la formation et l'emploi je
vous remercie la parole est à monsie
gessmar pour le groupe
démocrate ma ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre chargée des PME du
Commerce de l'artisana et du tourisme
madame la ministre lors de la Conférence
nationale du handicap en avril dernier
le président de la République a fait
d'importantes annonces concernant
l'accessibilité en reconnaissant le
chemin que notre pays a encore à partout
courir pour les personnes handicapées
comme pour l'ensemble de la société dans
la continuité de l'action résolue de ma
collègue jeune viève d'iosek en faveur
des personnes en situation de handicap
un investissement de l'état de 100
million et demi a été annoncé pour
booster la mise en accessibilité des
lieux publics et des espaces numériques
les espaces recevant du public comme les
commerces de proximité les restaurants
les bars dans nos villes et nos
campagnes sont les piliers du bien vivre
ensemble leur mise en accessibilité
n'est pas seulement une obligation
légale c'est surtout une nécessité
sociale c'est pourquoi il a été décidé
un fond 300 millions d'euros pour l'aide
et la mise en en accessibilité de ces
établissements recevant du public je
salue évidemment l'effort substantiel de
notre pays en faveur d'un meilleur
accueil de tous nos concitoyens mais que
comme vous le savez mes chers collègues
l'attente est longue pour les publics
intéressés aussi le temps presse
pouvez-vous nous dire Madame la Ministre
comment ce plan va être décliné avec les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques le
monde entier aura les yeux rivés sur
notre pays une phase importante s'ouvre
devant nous celle de la mise en œuvre
sur le terrain de ce plan pour réussir
ce derniers kilomètres je sais la
mobilisation madame la ministre de vos
services et de l'ensemble de nos
commerçants et établissements
accueillant du public afin de recevoir
dignement l'ensemble de la population
dans les meilleures conditions merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre chargé
des petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député gessmar merci de votre
question je vais
répondre aussi en mentionnant les
travaux de la ministre d' et en vous
confirmant qu'avec la ministre katabi
évidemment sous l'autorité de la
première ministre c'est un chantier
c'est un impératif et nous nous y
mettons tous et toutes très vite vous
vous souvenez sûrement monsieur le
député de cette phrase qui me mettait
très en colère donc je vais la partager
avec vous puisque j'ai poussé pendant 25
ans un fauteuil roulant on disait
beaucoup il faut changer le regard je le
dis et je sais que le ministre de la
Santé me regarde je crois que c'est plus
le regard qu'il faut qu'on change c'est
leur vie qu'il faut qu'on change quand
on on a 6 % de personnes handicapées
dans ce pays c'est leur vie qu'il faut
qu'on change et ça coûte rien ça coûte
quelques milliers d'euros de mettre une
rente d'accessibilité nous avons dans ce
pays et je sais qu'on sera tous d'accord
sur tous ces bans c'est assez rare
500000 établissements qui reçoivent du
publ des commerces des cafés des
restaurants nous avons une immense
majorité qui n'est pas accessible ça
n'est pas acceptable la ministre des
Sports avec lesquels on travaille on
partage ce point des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques responsables et qui
seraient pas accessible ça c'est pas
possible c'est pas une option donc le
gouvernement met 300 millions d'euros
pour les années qui viennent et 100
millions pour les mois qui viennent pour
qui pour toutes les villes mais en
priorité pour tous les commerçants et
les hôteliers les restaurateurs qui vont
accueillir des épreuves il y a un peu
peu de 70 collectivités concernés
comment à partir du 2 novembre prochain
sur le site de l'Agence des services et
des paiements ASP et comptez sur nous
pour le communiquer largement on
travaille avec les organisations
professionnelles tous vos commerces tous
vos hôtels tous vos restaurants vont
pouvoir bénéficier d'une prise en charge
de 50 % de leurs travaux par l'État dans
une limite de 20000 € je vous garantis
que ça permet de mettre en accessibilité
des dizaines de milliers de commerces
d'hôtel de restaurants ces Jeux
Olympiques ils nous honore mais ces Jeux
Olympiques il nous oblige et il y a une
chose on y va comment bah justement rend
ministre vous n'avez plus de temps de
parole merci beaucoup
alors madame la ministre je vous merci
de regagner votre place la parole est
Madame la
Ministre madame la ministre s'il vous
plaît la parole est à Madame Martine
Étienne pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé le 15
septembre vous lanciez une grande
campagne de prévention contre la
bronchiollyite cette infection
respiratoire qui touche les nourrissons
15 jours plus tard c'est déjà la pénurie
faute de dose de Fortus le produit
injectable qui permet de protéger les
bébés de la bronchiolite vous êtes
obligé de stopper la livraison en
pharmacie et de ne prioriser que les
maternités encore une fois vous n'avez
rien anticipé alors qu'il y a eu plus de
720000 naissence en 2022 vous n'avez
commandé que 200000 doses vous
souhaitiez créer un effet d'annonce en
prétendant anticiper l'épidémie mais
voilà aujourd'hui les doses manquent et
les parents s'alertent vous n'apprenez
rien de vos erreurs la broncholite c'est
quasiment 100000 passages aux urgences
l'année dernière des dizaines de
milliers d'hospitalisation et des
hôpitaux saturés qui ont dû gérer cette
épidémie la grippe et le covid en même
temps malgré ça vous Contin continu de
fonctionner en flux tendu de commander
trop peu de doses de renier sur les
stocks et de désarmer le pays face aux
épidémies monsieur le ministre il y a
urgence en 2021 sur l'ensemble du
teritoire 2700 enfants sont morts avant
leur premier
anniversaire les professionnels de santé
vous alertent sur la dégradation des
soins et sur la mortalité infantile mais
comme à votre habitude vous n'écoutez
rien la recherche et la santé sont
tellement sous-financé que la France est
dépendante d'une seule usine aux
États-Unis pour se fournir en médicament
contre la broncholy et soigner ses bébés
sous Emmanuel Macron les pénuries de
médicaments ont été multipliés par 7
parce que la santé n'est pas un marché
il est urgent de créer un pôle public du
médicament en France et de redonner les
moyens humains et financiers aux
maternités et à la pédiatrie alors
Monsieur le Ministre comment allez-vous
faire pour protéger la santé de nos
bébés merci merci beaucoup la parole est
à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de
la santé et de la
prévention madame madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée 4
qu quatre pays au monde ont commandé du
befortus la France l'Espagne les
États-Unis et l'Allemagne en mars
dernier un laboratoire est venu voir mon
prédécesseur François brog et lui a
proposé un traitement qui n'avait fait
l'objet d'aucune autorisation François
Bron a eu le courage et il a pris le
risque de commander des doses de ce
médicament qui n'avait aucune
autorisation aujourd'hui madame madame
si ce médicament n'avait pas obtenu les
autorisations qu'est-ce que vous diriez
sur le fait qu'on détruise des doses et
oui les sociétés savante à l'époque on
dit ça sera un nouveau produit donc sans
doute 10 % d'adhésion le ministère de la
Santé a commandé pour 30 % 200000 doses
nous avons commandé 200000 doses et oui
à la différence de vous madame je trouve
que c'est une formidable nouvelle que
dans les maternités on a un taux
d'adhésion entre 60 et 80 % jamais vu en
matière de vaccination ou d'immunisation
jamais vu et donc à partir de là ma
responsabilité et je l'assume c'est de
protéger les nourriçons les plus à
risque qui sont les nourriçons les plus
à risque qui sont ceux qui ont été les
45000 nourrissant hospitalisés l'an
dernier c'était ceux qui avaient
quelques jours ou quelques semaines donc
oui nous privilégions les doses de 50 mg
de bfortus dans les maternités et en
attendant plutôt que de nous faire faire
à nouveau la complainte des de de la du
drame nous travaillons au progrès la
premire ministre le président de la
République et moi-même nous nous battons
tous les jours pour obtenir plus de
doses et que pour que la France soit
comme elle le sera j'en suis sûr le pays
qui aura la plus grande couverture
aufortus dans le
monde je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre pour la dernière question je
donne la parole à Monsieur Paul mollac
pour le groupe lot
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Santé
monsieur le ministre caret Redon Pontivi
guingan le point commun de tous ces
hôpitaux la fermeture de leur service
d'urgence la nuit voire le weekend la
population les élus de caré manifestai
samedi dernier dans les rues de quimpè
les habitants du Pays de Redon ont
appris que la fermeture de service
d'urgence est prolongé jusqu'au 6
novembre je comprends les mois et la
colère que suscitent ces manquements
selon le syndicat SAMU urgence de France
163 service d'urgence sont fermé au
moins ponctuellement cet été c'est
catastrophique nous assistons à un
manque criant de personnel médical en
particulier de médecin ceci conduit à
mettre en danger nos populations qui ne
peuvent plus disposer de services
hospitaliers de proximité monsieur le
ministre quelle mesure envisagez-vous de
prendre pour que cette situation ne se
renouvelle pas et que les services
hospitaliers puissent fonctionner en
mode non dégradé dans l'intérêt des
patients et des
personnels je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Rousseau ministre de la santé et de la
prévention madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député oui la situation des urgences et
des services d'urgence en particulier
est dégradée oui elle l' été cet été il
n'y a et elle est encore à la rentrée
notamment en Bretagne et vous avez
raison de le souligner il n'y a
là-dessus aucune espèce de
dénis nous avons connu cet été sur les
680 services d'urgence que que
qu'accueille notre pays cinq fermetures
complètes et en effet un nombre on peut
discuter des chiffres mais en effet des
fermetures partielles de servicees
d'urgence qui sont qui ont obligé nos
concitoyens à passer par le 15 qui les a
orienté vers le service le plus proche
et ce qu'on appelle la régulation ça
n'est pas une situation satisfaisante la
plupart du temps et pour ne pas dire
tout le temps les raisons qui ont
conduit à ce système dégradé c'est du
manque de person
nous avons donc pris des décisions
fortes que la première ministre a
annoncé à rouan notamment l'augmentation
de 25 % du travail de nuit c'est une des
un des points essentiels de
l'attractivité nous avons pour
reconnaître le travail des des
assistants de régulation médicale
annoncé la semaine dernière une
augmentation de leurs indemnités et de
leurs grill de carrière nous continuons
à investir pour la santé mais vous avez
raison il y a des endroits où nous ne
tiendrons pas des services d'urgenence
ouverts sans difficulté donc nous devons
avoir un système dans lequel il y a
notamment pour les élus mais aussi pour
les citoyens de la prévisibilité être
associé aux décisions de l'anticipation
et croyez bien que sur le territoire de
la Bretagne et y compris sur celui de
carré nous avons des propositions et des
projets à faire même si en ce moment la
situation est particulièrement tendue et
je ne le ni pas il n'y a aucun sur le
service des urgences je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur mollac
monsieur le ministre j'ai bien entendu
mais je pense qu'il y a une mesure qui
qui manque en 2012 j'avais interrogé la
ministre de l'époque sur le sur les
déserts médicaux on m'avait répondu
monsieur mollac ne vous inquiétez pas
tout est sous contrôle il y a assez de
personnel en formation tout ça va se
régler voyant qu'on se moquait un peu de
moi en 2014 j'ai dit Madame la Ministre
les déserts médicaux ça continue vous
devez faire un effort particulier et
particulier sur le numérus closus en
2021 le numérus closus est devenu
numerus apertus vous l'avez augmenté de
20 % c'est bien mais c'est insuffisant
tout le monde le dit tout le monde le
dit donc il faut vraiment faire un
effort suffisant et dans un premier
temps je pense qu'il faudrait augmenter
le nombre de médecins en formation de 50
%. je vous le dis parce que vu la
démographie médicale le plus dur c'est
ce qui nous attend dans les 10 ans et
les 20 ans à venir je vous remercie mon
cher collègue la séance des question
gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue